the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
clever attacks and inspired defenses
abounded at the singfield cup in St
Louis we've passed the halfway point of
the event leaving fewer and fewer
opportunities to gain crucial tour
points with the standings knotted up
players pressed but even the most
interesting matchups ended in fighting
draws all except linear Dominguez who
blundered away a solid win against Hans
Neiman leaving Wesley so as the sole
leader of the event players are
re-energized and ready to bring their
best round six of stupendous Jets coming
up next
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
Cup held at the St Louis chess club it's
a beautiful sunny day here in St Louis
as we are waiting for the players to
arrive is the day after the rest day the
players are re-energized and ready to
battle over the chessboard let's go to
the studio and start today's action with
Yasser Peter and Alejandro
from the home of Chess in America
welcome to the sinful cup the
centerpiece of the St Louis chess season
and the final stop on the 2022 Grand
Chester
hello I'm Peter swidler and with me is
the silkiest voice in the business
you're coming up with all of these Peter
these are amazing hi nice to see you
hello everyone and Welcome to our
broadcast we have been in a chessic
hurricane and what a drama has been
swirling around us we were all deeply
moved by the impassioned interview with
Hans Neiman and his plea for
understanding but in the meanwhile an
actual chess tournament is going on the
final stop of the grand chess tour the
sink fill cup and Peter what are the
current standings in the tournament I
mean absolutely yeah absolutely there is
a bit of this you know I went to I went
to a fight and then a hockey game broke
out I've been into all of this but uh
there are there are the standings on
your screen uh Wesley is leading on
three out of five but that's only in
terms of points scored right if you if
you if you break it down as a plus minus
Score first currently with the
who also have the wanted plus one score
in the tournament exactly then there's a
number of people uh on 50 and three
people currently below the water line a
little bit are mdl
live on Iranian and chocolate and Peter
our format please
the form of this tournament is now a
nine play around Robin with 90 minutes
for the first 40 moves 30 minutes for
the rest of the game and a half a minute
increment from rule one uh draw first
are explicitly disallowed and one point
for a win half a point for a draw and
zero points for a loss is the scoring
system here our remaining schedule here
the rest is behind us so this is the
schedule we play we play Until the End
starting from today four rounds in a row
there will be playoffs on September 11th
if required immediately after the round
finishes and if the gcd tour points are
also tied those would be separate
layoffs which will be played on the next
day and then the closing ceremony is on
the 12th gotcha and Alejandro is really
good to see that you're still standing
nice my friend absolutely what a great
tournament to be casting with you guys
in the chess itself has been amazing as
you mentioned number wise it's Wesley so
at the top he does have a plus one score
that means that two other people are
technically tied with him but Wesley at
the moment is the one that's accumulated
the most amount of points in this
tournament and that's because of this
round three win against Fabiano Carana
with the white pieces that was what
catapulted him to the first place and we
know that wrestling is a very solid
player he's the type of player that
likes to grab his early leads in the
tournament and defend them he doesn't
really really do this aggressive all out
I must win every single game of chess
that's remaining he's happy with a plus
one score and when people realize that
this guy's leading they try to beat him
he says wait a second here I am and he
scores even more points let's take a
look at what's ahead for him because
it's a big one this is the first
classical matchup of course they faced
in online tournaments but this is the
first time that they play in a classical
time control Hans Neiman The Talk of the
Town we were playing with the white
pieces against Wesley so this is an
absolute must watch because this are our
leaders including Jana pomichi as both
of them are on plus one and let's take a
look at what else remains for Wesley in
the remainder of the tournament tomorrow
he will have the big buy he will not be
placing Magnus Carlsen as of course the
world champion has withdrawn from our
event and he will be faced with two
strong Fitness finishes with alireza
ferrugia and Lanier Dominguez to wrap up
this event so still anything can happen
today certainly a crucial crucial day
for the standings we know that Wesley is
an extremely solid player I want to see
exactly what comes out of that but
somebody that has had his mind in other
things this is important Hans Neiman as
the Twitter sphere has been going crazy
over him and his interviewer to tell us
more about that we have our social media
expert women's Grandmaster Anastasia
karlovich thank you Alejandro it's
really great to be here but it's also
great to be now in social media and I
ask all of our viewers all followers to
subscribe to YouTube channels of St
Louis chess club and of course to follow
Twitter accounts and Instagram accounts
of St Louis chess club and grantchester
because
lots of things are happening there so it
all started with the drama on the fourth
round of the sinkholed cup Magnus
Carlson made this crazy news announcing
in Twitter that he is withdrawing from
the tournament and you can see his Tweet
now on your screens and he also used the
video with famous football manager Jose
Mourinho and then after that of course
it was a big boom and we had lots of
comments lots of uh
um let's see ideas like why he did so
and uh later on Hans Neiman came out
with this famous interview the one
everybody have to watch
um so it's absolute must watch interview
and you can see the numbers which we hit
during these days in our YouTube channel
and in our social media so Hans Neiman
came out with the interview explaining
what happened and the commentator and
Grandmaster Maurice actually recommended
to everyone he said that he uh everybody
should watch this extraordinary
interview you know he never seen
something like this in his life and
after that of course you can imagine
that Hans Neiman didn't want to stay
silent and even though he he had this
good recommendation of Yasser not to go
to social media he still came out with
few tweets and of course the numbers of
his Twitter account raised dramatically
for last days after that of course we
can see lots of news in the media and it
created a big scandal in the Chess World
which everybody follows now all chess
fans they would like to see the
explanation what happened and there you
can see the chess will rocked by the
cheating accusations and this is my
favorite you know because after Carson's
pull out him and ready to play even
naked to prove his he doesn't cheat in
chess he said this during his interview
and you can see that it made headlines
in news as well so now after that
actually World cheers came also with an
original idea and decided to devote the
special tournament to Mourinho the
football manager who unexpectedly
appeared in the Chess World to celebrate
his appearance in the Tweet of Magnus it
was actually quite so funny and and
after that the Jokes Aside Gary casparo
also came out with tweets just couple of
hours ago and he says that Carlson
withdrawal with a blow to the chess fans
his colleagues at the tournament the
organizers and the rumors and negative
publicity swirl in a welcome so what
what he's trying to say that he is
asking for explanation from Magnus
Carlson and at the moment we can see
also Hans Niemann already he arrived to
the plane venue and he is carefully
checked by the chief arbiter of the
event but just to remind you that
actually yesterday was a free day and
our chess players as well as our
commentators Alejandra and Peter had
lots of fun they played some tennis
together I mean you can see also some
shots in the in our social media they
played some tennis games together and
also you can see the number Part One
tennis battles with Eric Rosen and
alireza Peru ropes and you can see all
of them on the screens so once again
please follow our social media you will
see lots of news and we are still
looking forward for Magnus Carlos and
explanation what really happened what
are the reasons behind his withdrawal
from the tournament and back to Yasser
ceravan today we have a special day we
had yesterday a very special day we had
a really important birthday thank you
Anastasia too many people having too
much fun but yes our founder rexingfield
check it out there you have it happy
birthday young buck and many many many
more to come once again for all of you
who are following this hurricane all of
this news you can reach out to us and to
Anastasia you can ask any questions you
would like of Hans Neiman we promise to
filter them and ask him he will be on
our show later as will our commentators
beat her we also we also are always here
but yeah once we we dangle this this
idea of asking questions
I think nobody's going to win the ratio
has got to be pretty embarrassing plus L
plus ratio yes exactly
um and let's take a look and happy
birthday Rex yeah I don't want to be
left out of those absolutely those
congratulations
um and let's take a look at the pairings
uh Peter do the honors what can our
viewers expect of this round six
absolutely uh the pairings for today the
central game of the round is divine
Alejandro has already spoken about it's
the game between Hans Neiman on the wall
on the white side again absolutely
Wesley so the two leaders facing each
other alireza is fighting against
playing against Maxima Sheila Graf both
of whom would really like to actually
start getting some points on on the uh
because uh they're currently trailing in
the fight for the GCT prize money and
our third co-leader Yani pomnishi is
playing White against Fabiano
as well yeah and as you can see there at
the bottom today Lanier would have would
have been playing Magnus but instead he
gets a Buy in the rest day how enjoyable
that is as we are about to start the
clocks I believe in fact the clocks have
been started yeah it appears to be
ticking down yeah a move or two on the
other
uh boards and there you see Hans Neiman
with the white pieces opening up one E2
E4 against Wesleyan of course Wesley has
been Berlin Berlin and more Berlin's E4
in the game
yeah uh E4 on three out of four boards
today and also uh uh an English in the
game between alireza and Shakira mijarov
as I can see on my screen at least one
night off already which is always a very
very welcome sight and neither of in the
game between Livonia onion and mvl and
Fabi is also uh actually uh showing up
with another of today instead of
potentially a petrol for some of the
more some of the most solid openings say
what say what
a time yeah some some kind of a small
thousand type type system yeah we don't
exactly know which one a key indication
that uh actually maybe he wants to play
the this vashnikov wire this move order
right we'll we'll see in a moment uh
having played E6 yeah Knight or six I
think is a kind of a heavy indication
that he will go Knight C6 now and give
Jan a choice between going live DB5 and
actually accepting the idea of playing
this version of ongoing Knight takes C6
and
already on the board so yeah okay
by the way it seems to me that uh quite
recently this line I don't even know
what we call this line by the way it's
really been getting a workout as well
right I mean absolutely we've seen we've
seen a lot of it uh I think it's uh it's
very much gaining in popularity I
believe we we uh we definitely covered
some high profile games well okay nose
fashion no especially for you today
this is very interesting because uh this
line
of uh I wonder what your impression
about it is because it I've oftentimes
thought of this line as a classical I
remember that Susan Polgar for one for
some reason found herself drawn to it I
always thought it was a long-term Edge
for white but first of all I want to ask
Alejandro number one what's the name of
this darn open it says four nights
variation of the Sicilian simply four
nights I'm guessing we can trust our our
own screens I also never know any names
of any openings and number two what's
the theoretical uh uh
evaluation if you will of this current
line the theory agrees with you Yasser
there's a slight but nagging Edge in
this variation for the white side in
most of the main lines but it does
require a lot of precision from y to be
able to prove anything and as far as the
name goes I do think anything that is
not Knight DB5 D6 specifically is just
called four nights including the line of
Knight takes C6 in the previous position
night night takes C6 also four nights
yeah it's uh even this is still before
yeah and this on our screen 96 says four
nights exchange variation which is yeah
you would you would want to give that
some kind of a more fancy name honestly
right yeah as for Bishop before for me
you know very few people in the world
are as as you know big of a fan of
having two Bishops uh as I am so I
always felt that this has to be uh
extremely good but obviously the
position after I assume D5 85 85 which
is the the main line here right uh the
position is solid black has I mean
decent development the knights are if
you have an isolating this is how you
want your Knights to be positioned it's
much better I think to have the Knight
on f610 only seven all things all things
being equal because it controls more
Central squares absolutely agreed and uh
in particular again somebody who hasn't
most likely repeated this prior to the
game because nobody really prepares for
this right unless they absolutely know
this is very a very integral part of
your opponent's repertoire nobody ever
repeats this right and in my
understanding uh
black will have decent decent chances to
equalize simply through sort of better
knowledge of what to aim for and just
the general kind of drawing margins of
of most chess positions but yeah this
shouldn't equalize like generally
speaking if this mathematically
equalizes so to speak I I'd be very very
surprised uh Alejandro Jump Right In as
Fabi played this line this this actual
defense I mean to say in his career
because it sure seems off the Beaten
Track it's played with white he's played
it with white he lost the game against
you Yang Yi a few years ago I will have
to dig that one up but I don't remember
him ever playing this variation with the
black side I'm going to have to look
that as well that would be my guess yeah
yeah I don't believe it I don't recall
ever looking at this with him to be
honest so it has to be very recent and
from the recent memories I don't think
he's played this at all very good and
thank you Alejandro and Peter uh what
are the games uh have caught your eye uh
there's an Archie game yeah you do have
a petrol yeah this one perhaps we can
sort of let this stew a little bit
because they've only made five moves and
uh right before they kind of determine
which kind of a better of this is we can
uh stay away this is also very very
early yet let's go to the neither
Factory because Knight of I think is the
most defined by this point and we've
actually seen this even in this
tournament already I believe right we've
uh this has been played move order right
it was that too once once again if two
of three so people seem to be uh hinting
that they suspect MBL of uh switching to
Knight G4 if given an opportunity
because there's really no other reason
to play three move six
um and then yeah what was that game that
was a game between uh
uh linear linear and MBL but that was
was that classical maybe that was a
representative
Fabi versus mdl2 from no no that was a
different line there was a 5B versus mvl
was a very very important game but that
was from uh uh assembling the rapid and
Blitz yeah but like specifically this
line with the pawn sacrifice where
Lanier played A3 G3 if you remember that
exactly that was a classical game right
that was one of the earlier rounds he
played a327 G3 and left today just
blitzes out Bishop D3 a move that used
to be considered to be the absolute
Central the absolute main move in this
position the move that I I played myself
and many other players as well there's a
like almost 100 games here a hundred
games yeah starting from this this has
become an incredibly topical line in the
past I don't know five years or
thereabouts
um so Levon continues to explore this
against MBL but changes uh changes
attack a little bit deviates from what
uh linear clearly believes too I feel
like I've got my resident expert sitting
next to me now that you've told the
whole world that this is part of your
repertoire and you played this break it
down fine I just play stuff
I never really know what I'm doing these
days I just play stuff uh I've looked at
this quite seriously but some time ago
and I don't really remember exactly what
uh what the currents uh like I remember
the general the the general feeling that
white is never worse but against precise
play uh you generally don't get anywhere
you like your compensation is always
going to be enough pretty much despite
despite it looking like the you know
Black's position is quite safe there are
no threats now and there won't be any
threats for I think some moves to come
honestly in a lot of cases there will
not be any threats for a while okay but
the two Bishops combined with a slightly
shaky setup combined with the fact that
castling King side with opponent H5
right is always going to be fraught with
at least some danger because then your
king side might just get blown apart and
you might get mated Yeah by moves like
G4 and uh so the night on D5 a little
shaky it's going to take like one maybe
two moves for it to get back yeah it
goes to BC sometimes it goes to C7 but
generally it goes to B6 if it goes
anywhere right uh but in terms of sort
of hard hard knowledge I used to have
some but without sort of checking my
notes it's uh
um it's just this general feeling that
black of course will need to be precise
black can't just make any random move
here exactly and think uh you're
completely fine but you're generally not
doing uh too poorly one line which I
think is relevant here please uh is
Queen C7 which is by far the main move
here I think we go rook he1 and there is
a very peculiar tactic there after long
castles which I wanted to show after
long castles yeah you can actually
immediately play C4 okay Knight b65.
is sort of forced to play Queen takes C5
leaving that night alive is not very
attractive and then we go Rook C1 Knight
C4
Knight C4 yeah and then we take on C4
with the rook and the bishop we take
back on D2
and this end game is I mean it's not
horrible for black but it definitely
because both both have seven and uh E5
are hanging we are winning one of them
immediately I think Rook H7 is the main
move here we go to take C5 through
Bishop D6 and
uh
uh Peter leko had this against uh uh
Alexander aresham didn't win and there
was also a game between Ray Robson and
uh Imperial chefchenko which why did win
it's an annoying end game I will
describe it as annoying more than
anything else the road just drops back
if you take on H2 Bishop C3 I think is
very painful and then you start getting
kind of shifted away from good Square so
I don't think you take on H2 I think you
do something else I'm not entirely sure
what but I'll I'll stop you right there
and say uh this is easy easy for me to
say uh play on one I mean
Rook H7 is the main line whoa okay Rook
F1 played so this is what left came with
haha I was very new idea yeah uh new
approach this may have been played but I
for me yeah actually well Queen C7 yeah
Rook hf1 almost non-existent or perhaps
actually just straight up non-existent
novelty yeah very very uh if this is not
can we take a yeah it is an F1 right can
we zoom in on this I just want to make
sure yeah
sometimes are kind of oversensitive and
in particular during the Olympiad we've
had a bunch of those uh weird glitches
where right if you're not carrying the
piece right through the air exactly
through its destination piece and you
kind of drag it across the board
occasionally the boards register it as
as having not reached the Final
Destination right so just for our
audience I'm going to take this move
that we think was played Rook F1 back
and we're going to play the move Queen
F2 instead but if you make the move
Queen from D2 to F2 and you press it
into the E2 Square sorry yeah sometimes
sometimes if the board is registered
sorry yeah it just gets registered as
that's your move yeah and then it it
happens particularly with longer moves
like let's say if black goes like Rook a
takes A1 some kind of a long trade along
the a file yeah in particular in the
Olympiad we've had a a number of those
registers like Rook A2 right and then
the the entire game score breaks down
and see if they are but it's corrected
manually
um okay but I think this is not what
happened here I'm pretty sure this is
what kind of telegraphs more or less I
have no idea well Liam intent has got to
be based on F3 F4 they put that on full
screen maybe for our producers just for
a second just for a second but I'm
pretty sure it's on F1 I can I can sort
of see it from here I think so we can
stop guessing right we can have a full
screen yeah
we're gonna take a look at the mvl
because it's a very I mean the screen
two things yeah the like the the boards
don't glitch in this tournament we
haven't had a single case and also mvl
is thinking those two things yeah kind
of indicate that it actually is Rook of
one because after okay q1 and VL
probably would have been still very much
in book right but like a four how big of
a threat is it for I can take twice I
mean okay yeah there it is it is yeah by
the way beautiful beautiful uh chess
pieces these a sink fill cup chess sets
um are available at auction uh and you
can own a piece of History uh they're
they're authenticated before the game is
played the players sign for the
provenance of the set and you can bid on
any set maybe you have to bid on one of
the Magnus sets because they're going to
be few and far between he played anyway
sorry Queen C7 and mvl is basically
saying should I Castle lung should I
Castle short Peter pretty much never
short but you can just keep it on the
eight in some cases the king is kind of
okay on E8 and if you have to evacuate
it King f8 King G7 also sometimes is
maybe safer than Gosling kingside okay
because with the Rook on h8 you're
slightly better prepared to G2 G4 breaks
okay but let's ask the the big question
first what happens if we actually Castle
here long yeah okay
c45 will be weaker because he fought in
in that same variation the polony 5 will
not be hanging precisely so why is it
yeah it's it's still going to be
somewhat playable but it's gonna I got
it I think he's depressing here uh
pressing four yeah okay but uh if I
before you have to play Bush B2 I think
pass pause
thinking about it thinking about it
Bishop F6 Bishop F6 Bishop E4 not C4
it's and then I I will unbean myself I
don't think I will get uh
some kind of a Perpetual pin shall we go
down that rabbit hole just a little
let's try it let's try it Bishop F6
Bishop F6 uh of course I have to
recapture the bishop Bishop takes E4
Knight takes C4 yeah and then maybe
Queen C2 or queen e so no itso I will
get bin myself no I don't think giving
black a Tempo to play Knight B6 is right
P6 I have Queen A5 though yeah that's a
very good point I'm still even though
the line is not finished yet like I can
go King B8 and then Queen E7 right
but there's probably a very very strong
initiative there for white like Rook C1
Queen is seven rookie one I might be one
yeah I'm with you I might be lost with
black already right we got to be careful
there on that one uh you but sorry but
you like the different move then I'm not
sure having looked at this variation
with you I'm sort of okay with Queen D5
honestly let's look at Queen D5 King B8
immediately Rook C1 or C1 Rook C8 and
ask you how are you attacking that night
next month
because I have Knight B6 and 93 against
Bishop D3 right I have some jumps yes I
will lose the F7 Pawn I I realize but
maybe that end game is not that horrible
I don't know
so that's just us
playing around just kind of throwing
things around none of this is forced you
know usual disclaimers we probably
blundered like 25 different things
already I like I like what Joel uh
Benjamin uh calls him we just throwing
the patties oh wait a minute Rook C4 oh
yeah dope yeah we did we did good
morning St Louis we did blunder at least
one big thing already okay that was the
idea behind that one throw in the
patties okay so c49 B6 F4 uh this is our
current let's pause here yeah let's
pause here and and think for a second
can I so we're imagining that black has
castled in the current game position
from the live position then we go C4
Knight B6 F4 and sorry back to you yeah
I'm wondering if there's a clever move I
can make with the F6 Knight just on on
being myself also I'm wondering is if is
fe5 as much of Australia though it's a
serious threat I think I think it is
yeah I think and illustrate what I was
asking and what the answer is I think
fe5d5 and of course that's the whole
point if we take one of six twice with
the Rook let's let's just go Bishop Rook
okay let's just go Bishop bishop and the
point is black does have E5 V4 seriously
winning the piece back but I think
before queen of two or yeah choose a
square I think yeah it is the best
square there's a hit against the bishop
so I don't think this tactic works out
for black meaning that the fe5 is a very
very serious threat by the way
everything we're doing to our audience
of course everything that Peter and I
are going through this is exactly how
Grandmasters thinks that that this is
exactly how we break it down we
investigate one line say oh yeah yeah
fe5 is okay and VL is going through a
similar process hopefully blundering
fewer pieces but not mates either yeah
hopefully but it will be a very similar
process to what we are exactly trying
trying to show here for for sure and uh
if we you were about to suggest that
maybe the night on episode I can't find
a square like 94h3 is just completely
pointless we just don't want to be doing
that I don't think although 90 no 96 we
can at least take take on E5 that's not
good uh so yeah 94 is definitely not a
move but something like 98 might be a
move but I'm kind of low through
to suggest moves like this like it just
feels wrong it feels passive we're
breaking connection between the roads
remember Ben Larson when his sausage
move is 98 says I don't play chess like
this and Knight B6 to F and then yeah
maybe the seven exists yeah but but then
F7 yeah yeah then our position is just
so passive and I start looking at ideas
like fe5d5 because you have to take with
the pawn here and if I could I would
very much like to play C4 C5 here just
to like introduce the idea of C5 C6
right and just generally improve my
Bishop on C4 a great deal I'm worried
about E5 before a little bit and then uh
the the X-ray along the G file might be
a problem but once again we're just
speed balling here there's uh I have no
idea what I'm doing uh it feels like uh
Rook H1 to F1 has to be taken seriously
absolutely I mean it's a it's an opening
idea by live on absolutely
yeah it's very weird this position after
Rook H1 to F1 because I'm just trying to
compare and contrast at something else
that Grandmasters do with the other move
the more natural Rook H1
to E1
but what's the difference that there are
a couple of scenarios in which there
there are significant differences for
example one of them was the end game
that you guys were talking about right
because we see those beautiful shots of
Levon aronian playing against Maxi
maximum deep in thought definitely not
familiar with the move for okay hf1 by
the way uh lavon's back in style with
the shirt there I mean that looked good
that looked really good guys I'm jealous
sorry uh uh Alejandra didn't mean to
steal your thunder so castles is
possible uh your guys were mentioning C4
and ib6 and C5 this line that you
mentioned going into the end game even
though the rook's not on E1 the engine
still gives us Mitch in the final
position after takes takes takes Rook C1
Knight C4 you mentioned all of this
takes takes takes takes takes and it
says that white it would be better if
black doesn't find the move Knight D5 I
don't know if Knight D5 is uh it's a
hard move to see but it's a very pretty
one and it's simple to understand the
point is that if Bishop takes D5 Rook DH
cures the Bishops yes white gets back
one of the pawns that he has down well
he's only down one so it's an even
position at the end and I'll draw is the
favorite in the position now of course
this tactic's not available if your
Rooks on E1 because of their Knight D5 I
have Rook takes E5 either before after I
capture the Knight so this just falls
apart now after Rook hf1 I was playing
around with the computer they do think
that castles is fine but after Castle C4
Knight B6 F4 which you guys were
mentioning it still puts pressure on the
black side I was trying to play around
with it Knight G4 seems to be an idea
you're trying to mention to move this
night somewhere 98 was not it E4 Bishop
E2 Rook H E8 is also possible the game
just kind of continues from that side
but the top engine moves are a little
bit weird the first one Rook C8 not that
weird but when you think about where is
this King in the center gonna go then
you start wondering if I really want to
play this move because yes it's I don't
know half open file yes it's an active
Rook but do you really want to prevent
me from castleing Forever how are you
going to solve the pressure on the king
side you know that if you ever Castle
short for example if your Castle short
in this position the move G4 comes in we
stopped counting pawns we just sacrifice
all of them because this king is going
to get blown apart so this is very
dangerous for the black side I don't
recommend castling short but a
surprising move that the engine does
like here in this position Knight H7
whoa it's a weird move but it takes
advantage of the fact that this Rook is
on F1 and not on E1 so that after you
take on E7 and I take with the Knight
it's a little bit easier for what for
black to defend the E5 Square for the
time being you're gonna have to hit the
spawn some at some point soon with the
Rook on E1 uh the recommended move is
Bishop E4 but this just runs into F5 or
castles in this position with the Rook
honey one there were some tactics with
the move F4 that seemed to work out for
the white side now after Knight H7 which
is a really weird move I do not expect
this at all I'm just going a little bit
through engine lines uh Knight H6 Bishop
H6 is supposed to be the best move and
then of course for black uh you could
Retreat the Knight on B6 but you could
also start maneuvering this guy and
that's a really nice maneuver the Knight
gets to E6 it's so much better than it
was on F6 where it was kind of colliding
with its own brother here on D5 because
the Knight on D5 wants to go to F4 it is
controlling some squares but the Knight
on E6 is going to help him there and it
just controls so many different squares
on the center so I like this move uh
Bishop h695 it could be possible I don't
expect a human to play like this like
Knight H7 yeah sir you said it very well
people don't play chess like that but if
you run it into an engine that H7 seems
to be fine Rook State seems to be fine I
more expect him to Long Castle however
wow thank you for that Alejandra Knight
H7 really uh opens uh uh the the the the
door of possibilities let's just jump
back to the game of uh nepo and afabi
for a moment uh our colleague in in the
truck as we say uh varusian uh draws our
attention to uh some
technicos as yeah and uh I've seen this
line before I I couldn't remember where
but uh yeah there's been some recent
games in this line and Fabi is
demonstrating sort of the the very very
concrete approach uh when I first got
introduced to this idea of just playing
Bishop before taking a C3 and playing G5
people were playing these positions much
more in a much more quiet fashion trying
to kind of uh equalize by by more uh by
more positional means but but Fabi is
doing is is extremely concrete Bishop G4
Bishop H5 is very logical because the
bishop on D3 is quite strong for black
to be able to play Bishop G6 and trade
it away I think most cases will be
extremely extremely advantageous welcome
by black yes which is why young
instantly goes Bishop G5 creating this
uh being on on the on the queen queen B6
checking H1 and it looks horrible for a
second honestly because Bishop takes F6
is coming where are you pushing this
Knight but Knight E4 exists using the
very very concrete thing that currently
the F3 Pawn is pinned by the bishopon H5
right meaning that we can play this very
striking move Knight E4 uh solving
digital so solving the issue of where to
put the F6 Knight Knight Knight takes D5
looks like it's winning for a second at
least until as as Yasser is pointing out
yeah at first I thought 1965 was winning
I was like guys what's going on here
after works I mean white steel has
compensation here but uh Black is Black
is up in exchange and I don't think you
you do that I just had to pause to make
sure that Bishop E3 finished yeah we
have only one square but we don't have
one square uh so yeah I'm very
understandable takes only for twice with
the pieces and Fabio instantly
recaptures on B2 this has also been seen
there have been even some recent games
yeah there was a game between uh
cindariff and jummabife in the battle of
the uh the Central Asian gifted
youngsters and some other games as well
why score is extremely well from this
position which I think is unsurprising
because white has the pair of Bishops on
a very very open board
but the structure on the green side has
been broken up the pawn on B2 has been
taken like if you move the pawn from A3
to B3 oh oh it's like borderline winning
right yeah yeah yeah yeah it said the
split pawns oh oh that's so nice unless
Blick can very very quickly Play Bishop
G6 and get rid of one of our Bishop pair
the pawns broken up uh you can see how
this might end up getting equalized by
black because once again the biggest
idea in the position here is to play
Bishop G6 and get rid of that monster on
e4 or it is attempt to get rid of that
well is Bishop on H5 is uh okay but uh
sorry after Queen takes B2 what how do
the variations continue Peter the main
movie the main move on our screen is
Queen B1 Queen B which is quite logical
I feel because I think black wants to
play Queen E5
uh why wouldn't you play rugby one I
think we're actually kind of valuing
having the A3 ball on the board Queen
takes A3 I think we can take it on Queen
C5 perhaps and queen C5 perhaps or queen
A6 here for some reason I don't know why
I would have played Queen C5 but I can
see on this is the queen D5 is sure take
Stakes are crazy and yeah okay yeah but
that's a poor end game I think I agree
with that yeah okay Queen A6 this is
what uh and once again it's it's an
extremely Temple heavy position because
if if white manages to preserve the
bishop there and not uh you know give up
any of their advantages in the next like
two moves right like seriously two moves
maybe why this may be borderline winning
because of just how strong the Bishops
are Knight 26 now has no uh support so
it will be kind of awkwardly placed
which is why they play Queen takes B1
sorry yeah but Queen takes B but if
black manages to play Bishop G6 maybe
it's not that bad and in this position
there is a split to trade on B1 or play
Queen E5 or
yeah it's it's a very healthy extra
point I I regret having to part with my
pair but uh a very very healthy Pawn on
B7 should be okay yeah and uh apparently
this is all steel Theory and F7 F5 is
what they play here a move I think which
is seven extremely easy to miss wow with
the idea being Bishop D5 cannot be made
by Bishop F7 which just about gives you
yeah and and each phrase uh saves the
part uh it feels like black is on the
razor's Edge uh they're Alejandro but if
he covers everything just perfectly
Bobby would be fine
yeah but how fine because after Queen B1
come on could be one takes takes on B1
with the F Rook the engines really do
prefer Africa over a rook uh we'll
figure out why later but F Rook is first
of all what everybody takes with and
second the preferred one of the engine
and they're saying just shed the pawn
bishop G6
takes takes takes on B7 and here I kind
of stopped this is not a Folly position
he's not going to defend down this Pawn
uh dump this Pawn end game it doesn't
look like enough to me the engines are
surprisingly saying only like plus 0.5
plus 0.6 I expected this to be more
considering you have a bishop yes I
understand this Pawn is a little bit
weak and blockaded but I don't expect
this from Fabiano he's not the type of
person that goes into a pawn down
position just to defend it in the long
run I think that the move F5 does not
solve Black's problems because after
Bishop D3 the engine does give a very
big advantage to White after B6 just
holding on to the pawn rookie won and
the problem is the structure the spawn
on F5 is just really badly placed
there's a lot of light Square weaknesses
this bishop isn't going to be able to
trade itself which is the main point of
the position right so I was playing
around with it and I'm gonna guess that
if nepo does play Queen B1 I would guess
that he's going to play Queen B6
this is going to be my prediction still
we have Bishop G6 on top for the next
move trying to trade off that bishop and
you can see the point that even if I
ruin my structure here it's still two
pawns and somehow I've opened up my Rook
towards the A3 Square now for example
let's say that they go something like
Rook fp1 yeah it's thinking at this
point I can't go Bishop G6 and sure you
can take take and go takes on B6 but
this is the type of concreteness that uh
okay take
concreteness that I'm talking about from
Fabi because here the line continues it
just does not end Knight D4 attacks the
pawn if C3 you have Knight C2 then
Knight takes A3 there's some positions
in which this particular King is going
to be uh worried about the first rung
problems and this would all still be
following a theoretical game the game
between Aldi ban baskaran and I am sorry
for this player I know him very well but
I've never been able to pronounce his
Knight's name
I'm not really sure he's a strong
Grandmaster I want to say from
[Laughter]
Knight C2 and it kind of goes on because
Rook C1 then you take on A3 and then the
computer somehow managed to blockade
this Pawn on C4 and it says it's not so
bad and boom Queen B1 played and
instantly Queen B6 yeah I might not know
last names but I know how far he plays
Chess at least a little bit Yeah bravo
bravo Alejandro he guessed it absolutely
yeah since everybody else did I I'm
going into you to take my stab at I
think it's Bella sen but I I have no
idea as well yeah I hope you get a nice
email from him
nice one please we are we are deeply
sorry
I am sure I am going to get a thank you
note by the way absolutely
yes cinnamon cakes at least that's my
that's my story Queen B6 uh but boy I
have to tell you uh
it yeah I I I followed Alejandro's uh
analysis there very very carefully but
at the end of the day even that position
where you get the nice blockade Peter
no that one I think is kind of drawn I
mean of course of course he like never
wins any of them but I think you hold
this whole Bishop G6 I think you think
fabby's willing just to go into it well
I mean clearly he is isn't he yes I mean
he's he's already kind of uh announced
that this is what he's aiming for uh
yeah see three Knight C2 uh yeah we're
still following the game between uh
audiban and uh the the French player the
French and and this is 19.3 rugby seven
and we can play
um was Rook fc8 was played in that game
but I think at this point the the VR
moves matter less because I think what
we're going to get is the Knight on C4 I
would like to play F7 F6 at some point I
would very much I think like to trade
one pair of Rooks maybe so that we don't
get mated I'm actually kind of torn
because I think it makes the future
bringing of the king closer to the C3
Pawn for white easier if there's only
one pair of Rooks on the board but on
the other hand if white light goes H3
and doubles on the seventh and we have
no counter play against that we just do
that
so uh you know discussing end games like
this could be either an extremely
tedious thing or it could lead to some
very interesting discussions about uh I
think a topic that rarely gets discussed
properly as as the like the preferred
trades and end games like which which
material balances here you would like
with black which you wouldn't for
instance yes as a thought experiment
please
is why training is off if if all four
hooks get traded off and black gets the
king to D5 and Knight is on C4 it's
right winning or not
probably not the pawn is on G7 my the
reason I'm asking is if if the structure
on the king side was healthy was healthy
I think black is safely okay okay but
because there is this Pawn on G7 which
in particular is quite true let's say if
white gets to play h2h4 and you never
you can play F6 but you can never play
G5 so there is this backward Pawn on G7
and perhaps I could just demonstrate
like if we're spending so much time
discussing this let's play H4 here right
and then just find a way to immediately
get all Four Oaks
I mean these are stupid moves please
dear viewers we are not we're not
intending to actually make them in real
life exactly and let's say F6 Bishop I
don't know E3 or F4 doesn't matter Rook
B1 yep yep yep yep yeah take stakes and
then we will not be taking on C3 next
move King F2 King F7 King E3 right King
E6 right King G3 King G5
Knight A3 check all this is obviously
completely pointless but just to
demonstrate King D3 Knight C4 this kind
of music we're in this position that
thought experiment please and I think if
the pawn is on H7 instead of G7 I think
we're holding this somewhat comfortably
yeah you just make a check you go back
and say I mean never break the block
yeah the king could try going around
like c2b3 before B5 and somewhere but my
feeling is it pretty much never actually
wins the game even though of course
white is very safe and can try forever
but I don't think we win and then but
with the ball on G7 I'm worried that
because it might be a a line where a
bishop Bethpage shows on your doorstep
perhaps we can organize yeah some way
because currently this bishop on F4 it
looks beautiful but has no squares like
you can go back to C1 but then I don't
C4 still dominates it completely right
uh so even this may be a maybe it's a
draw but just to demonstrate what could
potentially go wrong of course again to
play and everything but if if we're just
making bad moves for a while this is the
this is a potential problem and why this
is how you might lose it right wow that
if the pawn were on H7 as you said a
healthy structure instead of the double
pawns the pawn on G7 is the Achilles
heel so absolutely and an interesting
thing is uh that adiban bilasan game
even though I suspect like just aimed
for this end game from the outset
actually finished in whitewinning did it
yes okay like in the one game that
reached this position black even though
once again I'm pretty sure he was
specifically aiming to get this end game
is a higher rated player of the two he
perhaps has you know uh if we look at
the Raging perhaps a bit of a skill age
there but still it's it's a kind of an
interesting little fact and in the
meantime uh Knight H7 Bishop H6 on the
board in levon's game something
something we said will not happen has
actually happened by the way uh the move
uh we could be one on the board already
yeah what was it already on the board
because I did sneak a look at uh at
Alejandro's board and I did see that the
engine for whatever reasons didn't
really think that the Rook on B6 was as
well placed as the bishop maybe the
agencies as H6 upon me this F6 uh Bishop
double double G pawns coming up and gets
the bishop out of the way maybe yeah
Bishop three definitely uh definitely an
option it also limits the Knight on C6 I
think one of the reasons uh it might be
suggesting which by three is either the
first or the second choice here is like
if we continue exactly the same as with
the other game yeah take Stakes we take
one B6 we're not allowing 94. that is
important for the time being we're just
not allowing 94 at all so maybe we get
to play like Rook B1 rugby three if the
bishop gets attacked we protect our
Queen side and then we try to play a
slightly different material uh balance
position with an extra Pawn but for the
time being let's move away from here
this is
we will mention let's put this up on the
board for a second that Knight H7 page
six has been played Levon took also not
Lebon and we all took about 25 minutes
to play Knight H7 the one of course is
still blitzing because Knight H7 is
definitely one of the top computer moves
so there is there's no chance that one
has not checked this right and I think
Perhaps it is time for us to take a look
at the Petrov in our absolute main game
because they have defiers they have
defined which pattern of it is so we can
actually finally start talking about it
okay our two leaders uh that is to say
Hans Neiman is white Wesley so have
reached the patch trough and as you said
we were waiting for them to Define what
type of a veteran light Square Bishops
are coming off Peter yeah this is still
uh this is still a very very heavily
trafficked uh traffic position even
though uh B3 is a bit rare I think
everything up to 93.97 we were still
following or at least 93 but we're still
following uh heavy Grandmaster traffic
if we go back one move Knight E3 yeah
after Knight D3 there is still uh some
games by Vichy actually two games by by
Vichy from 2019 he had this pushing
against also against widget and yuyangi
himself played it from the white side
and this kind of confirms uh kind of
confirms what I wanted to say that in my
mind I keep on saying this but like in
my mind the popularity of these
particular setups were black and the
best of gosb7 which by five and then
aims to trade the light Square Bishops
and play this kind of a slightly passive
slightly underdeveloped in the beginning
with a very very solid positions sure it
is very much associated in my mind with
the the efforts of the Chinese players
UNG in particular but also I think Juan
Hal played a bunch of this right uh and
our screen there was kind of confirming
that right
um and B3 is a kind of an interesting
very concrete way to play here uh what
was the popular move instead of them
this is not not such a frequent position
but rookie 2 looks logical H4 looks
logical there's a rookie too just
doubling green
h495 is something that they often try to
at least organize in these types of
positions uh but Hans is playing it in a
kind of a somewhat new manner he goes
b2b3
which is obviously an immediate
indication that white wants to place it
to C4 right and generate pressure
against the black center this way which
makes perfect sense frankly it makes it
makes absolutely absolute sense I am
being told that B3 is not in the
database I think it's going to very well
be a novel novelty but like you say
sorry to interrupt you but c2c4 I mean
that is a that is a break it's gaining
space it's hitting a pawn in the center
why not 90 seconds we should be fine
yeah I I quite like this from White
because I think the bishop 25 is a bit
annoying you pretty much never want to
play F7 or six in these types of
positions because it weakens your
king-sided great great deal it's pretty
much never a good movie yeah yeah not to
mention that the Knight could easily
become a tactical absolutely yeah I'm
actually a bit surprised Wesley played
96 so quickly because if we go back for
for it to here yeah I like the Knight on
C7 defends D5 exactly because the 1966
sort of makes the threat of C4 stronger
right because now if if you don't have a
good reply in the current position after
96 Bishop P5 if we put that on the board
if black makes some kind of an
indifferent move like okay I think
generally is what they do like the
Cambridge Buffet is a very very large
part of it but the G5 is already hanging
we're definitely will take it yeah with
Glee in fact we're definitely very
unhappy about the idea of going Geisha
for bc4 because that gives white
mobility in the center you don't like
like Rook 81 this looks kind of bad
like my years of looking at various
petrovs suggest to me that this is about
as ideal ideas
beautiful pieces all in the center Rook
on a a queen on d8 still out of the game
and yeah the move 96 Bishop E5
those two moves just weighing them by
the way it just feels like the Knight on
E6 is not particularly good and uh we'll
see I mean there might be Concrete
Solutions here uh perhaps Alejandra can
tell us something let's take a look at
it because you guys had a brilliant
explanation about everything that's
happened including the fact that there's
only one good move here for black so
what is it because C4 is coming and it's
difficult to stop the engines are very
adamant that you must play the move
Knight E4 to remain with an equal
position what's the idea well C4 is why
it's planned there are other moves but
let's go with the move that's natural
the move C4 and now the point is that
you go Bishop B4 this is an annoying
move for the white side taking advantage
of the weakness of the dark squares
played by B3 and C4 Now The Rook would
love to study in the E file but it
doesn't have that many squares if you go
here then after F6 Bishop G3 you're
gonna have to be worried that sometimes
the Knight F4 is coming the Knight C3 is
a double attack against The Rook on D1
eventually coming to D1 and The Rook on
E2 to and the moment that you put the
pawn on A3 to a victim my Bishop I will
be very happy to retreat it all the way
to f8 where it's going to hit the spawn
on A3 which again it's not trivial to
defend and now what's another point of
the move 94 in this position you open up
the queen to the defense of D5 so it all
kind of works out together also
important that if you do go to another
Direction it also makes my F6 so much
more comfortable right after Bishop G3
I'm not really worried about this Knight
on E6 is going to get hit by the tactics
that you were mentioning so the engine
saying the move here is Knight E4 it
clocks the e-file allows me to play F6
defense D5 against the eventual C4 and
it makes Bishop B4 possible and annoying
for white so it's a very multi-purpose
move there's no direct refutation so 94
is the indicated one in this position
wow uh it's very strange how my mind
works I saw an echo there of the game
with Ali Reza for just a brief moment
after the move Knight E4 I saw this
Knight at five Bishop B4
of course
I don't know the night check Ouija board
sorry
you you you're absolutely right I was
trying to like I I realized that Honda
was about to recommend 94 because I can
see his board and I thought why was I
blanking on this and I think it's just
that
the night has gone from E4 to D6 so in
my mind in these lines like you it it
doesn't jump back yeah it feels like
this is where it belongs like Blackberry
actively puts it on D6 and keeps it
there in a lot of these types of
positions but it yeah it definitely
needs to be on e4 here uh because white
doesn't have a very uh comfortable way
of driving it away
um so we'll see if Wesley finds it
Wesley generally has a lot of experience
in this type of structures so I would
probably bet on him to uh to find it and
play it but it's not uh I don't think
it's such a straightforward decision and
there's one game which we've been like I
said I said it was an English opening at
the very very early moment that was it
and this is actually one of my all-time
favorite uh lines of the English I've
played it a decent amount with the white
pieces a little bit with black as well
but mainly with the white pieces uh I
won a very nice game against Fabi one
year here I think it was in 2017 when I
was when I was a wild card in a single
cup replacing some somebody who couldn't
make it it wasn't exactly like this but
this this idea if we go all the way back
oh sorry it's which moment yeah just
just this idea of playing G3 move 2
following it up with uh if we go
so c45 G3 Knight F6 Bishop G2 and these
days blackplay C6 uh quite a lot you
obviously can still play g75 but there
is definitely an argument to be made for
why to kind of not play Knight F3 very
early and this is the reason this Movado
became popular instead of C6 if you play
let's say D5 here okay uh we take take
we play Knight of three oh no sorry not
C3 right and if black plays Knight B6
there is at least a possibility of
playing something like D3 Bishop B3 Rook
C1 make all kinds of useful moves
without developing the G1 Knight meaning
to the moment the Knight appears on C6
and at some point the hope is that black
runs out of other useful modes right and
then we just snap it okay and we're
going out of three uh any other there is
this is apparently something that I've
done I've done myself without much
success yeah apparently I lost I lost
the game in this position to uh L Dodge
safarily many years back I don't
remember that game at all three specs
you know press F but
um
fail got it yeah but this is sort of the
point and this is why you uh sometimes
uh postpone Knight F3 for as long as
possible but a way to reply to it is of
course to places 76 because the Knight
is not on C3 and black is trying to
assume control in the center right and
here you go uh United 394 so it's a kind
of a sort of a you know some kind of a
Weird Al yankin with colors reversed
Within an extra Temple and 25 Queen H5
is probably the most popular and the
most critical way to reply and you get
these types of positions which are very
very quirky and very very interesting to
look at because there's uh so many
strategic ideas that can be utilized by
both sides also famously not exactly
this position but this structure
featured in round one of the Madrid
candidates where
yeah but a very very nice position out
of the opening in that game and then
just started going astray you just
you're right and ended up just getting
mated on the king side after Bishop 3g3
in that structure but I mean he began by
having a very uh a very nice position
and I remember talking about you know
opinions on the candidates that game
featured very very largely in that kind
of Infamous video by Vladimir kramnik
on the topic of oh my God what am I
watching why is this the candidates
tournament we're saying of endeavor I
get it yeah uh Queen C2 so you you like
these positions for white you like the
rich nature yeah the tapestry I'm not
suggesting white is better I just really
really like this structure because I
think
it's about as uh non-standard and as
reach a structure as you can get it's uh
unlike almost anything else in in
current opening theory if you if you
talk about you know somewhat fashionable
things that you see at the top level uh
so I'm very happy we're watching this I
think it might be an extremely
interesting game but everything is still
in progress in terms of what black wants
to do like if you could teleport the
knight from B8 to D5 he would be
extremely happy so I'm wondering if I
can play Knight A6 Knight A6 Knight
season yeah and then if you go A3 which
I assume is at least you know a playable
move yeah yes uh then I yeah I just want
to go Knight C7 and I want to play 95
there and if it lands there I think
black's problems are immediately uh
solved to a very large degree now I'm
looking from Whiteside and I'm asking a
Salient question where am I putting my
king I really don't like the King on the
queen side I really don't like the king
in the center so by default that leaves
me
yeah this this doesn't look horrible at
all horrible I I'm feeling like I'm the
one trying to equalize now
yeah and this is why the structure is so
fun because I don't know if white is
worse maybe white is completely fine but
you get this it's so difficult to
navigate and
to me it makes it extremely attractive
because it's it's just so you know felt
provoking uh if we can use a kind of a
highfal way to describe it well I'm
sitting there scratching my head because
I'm thinking look I got H4 H5 issues in
the the position I'm not really happy
that I'll end up with double pawns by
five if that setup happens and white
steel hasn't developed anything in the
center on the queen side you just start
getting mated on the king size which is
precisely what happened which is what
happened in the game yes
so let's maybe go back for a second like
Quincy 2986 is it possible that he's
intending to play before B5 because I
think in general before B5 is something
that white would welcome okay it opens
up files for our play on The Queen side
it's also like if you have to take on B5
your ideas of putting something on D5
later in the game have taken a kid I
will I'll take it before and I'll just
say okay you you so this me uh it's just
putting my knight on B5 no I thought
maybe I will you know you being the the
president the pond Grabber the president
of the pong Grabber Association yeah
maybe I will I will kind of scare you
away from the sacrifice I I I I'll only
uh uh
switch hats uh when I have a very very
very promising initiative and just
because I don't yeah
precisely I I could I could see some
scary no if I if I have a discussion
with white I'm I'm worried I'm I'm
worried I don't know that I'm doing
poorly but I'm worried for sure right
like maybe I can play you before exactly
like and not because I'm such a greedy
greedy bastard but because like if I
allow Rook 88 I get the feeling I will
not be able to challenge those pieces
anymore exactly but we're getting very
carried away even like day six hasn't
been played yet other moves are also
absolutely available so we'll we'll get
back to that so let's invite our
colleague Alejandra in on this
discussion between Ali Reza and shakiri
are a very topical line double-edged
position
Rich
strategically but also tactically
Alejandro yeah and the entrance in this
particular one at least the one I'm
using is favoring black slightly after
the move 986 you covered that after a397
it's all good the question is an ibd7
already played as I'm saying that so
none of this is going to be relevant but
uh Knight A6 seemed to be the slightly
better move according to the end just
because takes takes takes just take the
pawn on B5 Bishop D7 you start getting
hit quite a bit you start losing a lot
of Tempe in this position Knight before
still on tap Rook C8 coming and you've
mentioned all of the problems on the
king side that can occur even if I just
take and snap this Knight off on E3 so a
little bit worrisome instead mamad yarov
has decided to put the Knight on D7 it's
actually by transposition takes us to a
couple of games
last from the past uh Christopher Ward
playing against Bogdan loudly oh can we
get an interview please
yes definitely Crystal Christopher
Warren interviews are they're so full of
energy yeah like I I I understand it's
so slightly off topic but I just won
that interview can we we have some
English Connections in this uh a shout
out to Chris who actually I learned the
Sicilian Dragon through him his
enthusiasm on a DVD series back in the
day called foxy chess openings right
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it was it was
very
the production wasn't there compared to
today it was basically him on a you know
white background and a demo chess set
sometimes following on a 2d board and
that was it that was absolutely it but
he learned he like was passionate about
the dragon I learned all of it thanks to
him and scored a lot of Victories when I
was a kid so this particular one after
Knight bd7 it seems that the engine
likes the move H4 to make this queen a
little bit uncomfortable that's not
usually the way humans play I think
castling is okay in this position you're
not so worried about taking on E3 right
away especially with the bishop on B2
sometimes preventing this rule coming
from E5 too quickly and because this
bishop is now not attacking H3 directly
right so you get that extra Tempo to
perhaps finish up your development and
that might be what you want to do so I
like castles the engine is pretty
adamant about H4 now let's update
another game here Levon aronian playing
against Mexico we had this cool idea of
Rook hf1 Maxine playing like a computer
Knight H7 on the board quickly was met
with Bishop H6 quickly Maxim put the
Knight back on F6 well not that quickly
he did a little bit of time on that one
it doesn't hit the bishop remember that
the queen is defending it but it does
return the Knight to a very good Square
now after Knight hf6 C4 Knight B6 Bishop
G7 kicked out the Knight and this move
Bishop G7 forking the rook and the
Knight a clear indication that I'm going
to take his next move the question is
where does The Rook go and for the life
of me I cannot figure out why G8 is a
worse Square than H7 because I would put
it on ga yeah neither neither could MBL
yeah and I don't think I don't think
anybody anybody I don't think anybody
yeah Rook H7 is just not a move right
not a move yeah unless you know it but
the engine does think that Rook H7 is a
better move than Rook G8 I don't really
know why we'll take a look later
hopefully at some point some of the
variations will tell us why but this is
the current position on the board the
edges like both Rook C1 or Knight A5
keeping up the initiative and one day
deep in the analysis I'll be able to
tell you guys why the Rook on H7 was so
much better than duracon G8 but the
engines do think that after Rook C1 in
this particular moment uh follow with
the Geo Bishop B4 follow with the idea
of C5 it might get a little bit tricky
for uh for the black side I'm starting
to wonder how if it has something to do
with the fact that you need to play King
fa King Jade but as I'm saying that
Levon plays the move Knight A5 at least
that's what I'm being told and which I
think you spend no time it's uh it's one
of the top top lines so I think he is
very much still uh yeah I wouldn't I
wouldn't at all be surprised if he is
still in book Because as we mentioned
Knight H7 is first line after Bishop
page six Knight F6 probably isn't the
best move but it's the most human move
just pushing it back saying your Bishop
was perfect on G5 I have misplaced it do
something about it that is not a
three-fold repetition with just putting
it back on G5 and then you like you you
look at what the the the engines are
suggesting Bishop G7 is definitely one
of the suggestions in Knight A5 if it
actually gets played because it's not on
my screen it's not on my screen either
yeah but Knight F5 I saw there that was
basically between Knight A5 and Rook C1
so if it gets played once again no
surprise and should actually have been
analyzed by uh by Levon this is not that
outlandish that he still knows no not at
all and based on the time situation you
would think that he's still in theory
yeah I I recall a game I had played
against Boris basket as a young young
man and playing you know the great Boris
basket and he had just exactly that type
of dilemma Rook G8 or Rook H7 and he
made his decision and I asked Boris
after the game he won the game against
me I asked him well why did you choose
the one over the other and I was looking
for some great you know Insight that I
could use in the future and he said well
I I made a mental coin flip and I just
chose G8 over here and and you often do
this like this is a slightly rare rare
case but when we for instance if you
have to choose there's a lot of
positions where like you're choosing
between recover D1 and kg1 right and
there's just no way no oh yeah always
wrong yeah and you you spend some time
because like due diligence still has to
be attempted at least right so you spend
some time trying to figure out what the
differences are very often in the
Practical setting when it's a game and
not analysis there is just no way to
figure out exactly so you do kind of do
make this mental first as we prepare to
go on break I just want to bring up uh
the viewers today in the Marquee matchup
between Hans Neiman and Wesley so indeed
Wesley did find that before Alejandro
prescribed the engines only move Knight
E4 but after C4 he didn't follow up with
the consequent Bishop B4 rather he just
slipped back with the Knight just put it
on F6 a passive position I assume I
assume he has to be a bit worse here at
the very absolutely it doesn't look I
mean it's solid but the night and go to
F5 now and it will be very difficult to
smoke out you can also start doubling on
the e-files I love those ideas and in
this case I can actually double on the
e-file maybe in a nicer way E3 as
opposed to E2 The Rook is a little bit
more ready to do a Rover Rook up and
over uh Knight F5 looks looks like
hanz's problem it looks promising
promising for Hans for sure as we go on
break uh absolute audience what they can
expect from Cuba yeah I will I will talk
and you will be the the two very nice
specimens in front of me magician's
assistants as they are demonstrating the
Wares yeah so today we are uh promoting
the uh single cup stemless wine glasses
and mugs uh there there you see them on
your screen the stemless wine glass is
finished with a single Cup logo and is
dishwasher safe which is very important
I've ruined many of many a nice piece of
me too
like a person where this is another
thing where no I've that's that was the
in my case is this like etched laser
crystal glass by putting them in the mic
and the the the the 16 ounce mug is a
navy blue with a single Cup logo as well
and there's also dishwasher safe so
that's uh that's a good thing about them
uh they're very very nice they're kind
of they feel nice in your in your hand
I'm holding one up right now and uh they
they they they they they seem very
comfortable in your hand and look nice
so that's uh that's our today's promoted
product and as with everything else it's
available at
cubicstl.com so do take a look and can
folks get a five percent uh friends and
family discount on these by I don't feel
like some code
all right everybody we're going to take
a break we'll see on the other side
[Music]
hey St Louis the Ascension Charity
Classic presented by Emerson is back
this September don't miss the excitement
when the PGA toured Champions best
compete again all for charity September
9th through the 11th at Norwood Hills
Country Club Pro-Am spots Hospitality
packages VIP tickets and more available
now at Ascension charityclassic.com
we all know St Louis is a championship
Sports Town from the 11-time world
champion Cardinals to the Stanley Cup
champion Blues
but I bet you didn't know about all the
championship places there are to get out
and play here like the World Chess Hall
of Fame Westport social and Topgolf and
now even our own MLS team so whatever
Sports your team is into you can always
bring out your A game in St Louis
oops sorry St Lou is always exploring
[Music]
St Louis University celebrating its
200th anniversary offering world-class
education in the heart of St Louis SLU
attracts students and professors from
around the globe
in 2015 slew partnered with the St Louis
chess club to start a top-tiered
Collegiate chess team on the very first
year of the team's Inception slew
obtained second best university of the
Pan-American Intercollegiate chess
championships
higher purpose greater good
St Louis University
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dot com
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
thank you foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
round six of the sinful cup is in very
very much in progress with a lot of very
interesting positions and I think it
will be a very very exciting round for
us to follow but for now there is some
unfinished business here absolutely
absolutely uh Peter these players are
fighting hard and they're fighting for a
lot of money shall we break it down for
our audience what's at stake absolutely
uh the GCT classical tournaments have a
prize a total prize fund of 350 000 and
there's a very cool six figures some
there at the top for the winner with 65
000 for second and 48 for third and
there's also GCT uh points that's very
very important I must say and uh with
the very very prominent wild cards
leaving the tournament after three
rounds uh some of those GC points have
sort of uh back in the back in
contention there so a lot to play for
because the granchester uh has its own
pairs with a hundred thousand uh for the
winner of the gstu standings 50 for
second and 25
000 for third very very nice and of
course there's also a special
bronzi prize Peter absolutely as you can
see on your screen an additional five
thousand dollars is very kindly donated
by Brian preserve Key West Florida and
we the four of us Alejandro yes sir
Anastasia and myself will be the judges
of that yeah we will determine what's
brilliant I like that thought and let's
just jump right into our Marquee matchup
the game between Hans and Wesley when we
left it we left it in this position
Peter Knight F6 yeah we took our break I
was passing by Alejandro's Green in
studio and I was really surprised by the
move rook ad1 and that Knight F5 had not
been played and I looked at Alejandro's
green and it wasn't even the First
Choice Knight F5 just didn't even show
it's interesting yeah and they've been
playing very very quietly since Hans
made a move through kg1 which I think is
sort of sensible but uh we were
discussing the idea of doubling on the
e-file but getting the Rook behind on
the G file is also uh very
understandable then they someone I mean
G6 is not a mysterious move G6 is
something that Blick often does in these
types of structures because yeah
stopping Knight F5 is sensible G3 I find
uh somewhat more difficult to explain to
explain it's not a bad move by any means
you often want to you know create a loop
perhaps play G3 King due to uh but I
would suggest that maybe there are more
urgent things you can be trying to to
achieve here but he's gone G3 uh Wesley
played A6 which I think maybe you can
explain by the fact that maybe in some
positions uh you could arguably go like
Bishop takes F6 then C takes D5 and then
Queen B5
attacking both the pawn on B7 and the
pawn on D5 and now that Westlake has
played A6 that idea of course has been
completely completely stopped so for
example let me just put a a port well
lesser choice if you will uh Bishop F6 I
don't know if it works but at least it's
an idea yeah and cd5 cd5 queen B5 here
and you do have to wonder if maybe white
actually wins material exactly but after
A6 of course this is not playable at all
and uh in the meantime after A6 uh Hans
played rookie one E2 once again one yeah
preserving the options I think if he
wants to double on the e-file later he
can double on the e-file later but for
the time being he's just making kind of
slow flexible somewhat improving moves
and passing the move over to West Lane
but I really have to ask Alejandro
Alejandro first of all the engine didn't
suggest the move Knight F5 in fact it
was not even that it's two top choices
for me the move is very attractive and
uh the engine just didn't even like it
why well the engine is just not
attracted to taking that Bishop on E7
actually the engine in many positions
will eventually like taking on F6 and
getting rid of the bishop saying it's
not a great piece so for example after
the move Knight F5 in this particular
position right and there exists this
move Bishop B4 you can also play rookie
and I played around it with it a little
bit and it was not so impressed but you
have the time to play Bishop before
right now and then on rookie to play the
move Rook E8 uh he just thought that
black was fine in this position so even
in positions where I returned the bishop
to f8 I'm gonna be okay you could try to
go for C5 but now you are strategically
risking a little bit because I do have
the move 94. it's absolutely forced but
it's enough because you have ideas of F6
you could take only four the computers
are not so impressed but they do think
it's possible I think Knight F5 is a
very active move but concretely they
were not a huge fan of the move they
actually like the way that Hans plays
the move for kd-1 with G6 and G3 trying
to get a little bit of space and on A6
which the engines didn't love they
recommended to actually go the move H4
directly just try to create more space
on the kings that you never know when
you're going to take on F6 and play H5
soften up some spots on the king side
especially with the queen on D3 eyeing
the G6 square but they're okay with move
rookie too rookie 8 played pretty
quickly and we'll see where this goes
it's clear that Wesley is on the passive
side but he's an incredible Defender he
doesn't mind having this slow slightly
passive positions against anybody so
only Doesn't Remind it I guess a
co-leader of the tournament when he's
playing with the black pieces and again
I've played around with the engine a
little bit I think Rook D1 is a very
normal move but on the other hand did
you really play Rook D1 to play Rook D1
it's a bit unnatural uh the engine stop
suggestion of taking on F6 taking on F6
taking on D5 taking on D5 and going
Knight E5 we're reinforcing this with F4
it's possible but again I don't like
giving up a bishop so easily right and
you're usually trained to not give up
this bishop unless it's for something
and again it's not like black is that
much worse in this position according to
the end just Knight takes D4 does work
but somehow the engine is think that
even in that endgame there's a tiny tiny
tiny bit of pressure I wouldn't think so
I would never go into this variation so
I expect more or less for him to go
either Rook D1 or push something like H4
at some point I like to move H4 in
general it's just a good idea to start
hitting things on the king side get some
space but the engines think it's still
about equal in this position let's go to
a more fun one this one
we left it off here after the move
Bishop takes up 6985 which was played
and King f8 was Maxine's decision just
trying to uh hide the King on G7 uh the
engines think that check I'm going back
is simply a threefold repetition there's
no reason to throw that check in so
Bishop B4 was played it was played
pretty quickly as well targeting the
pawn on B7 and here the engines kind of
went a little crazy because they want to
take on C4
and after Knight takes C4 Queen takes C4
they actually don't mind that you take
on D6 with the tempo and I thought that
it would be a little bit dangerous to
stick this bishop on E7
uh but King G7 and they just don't see
any problems Bishop D5 trying to hit
something on F7 trying to say that Queen
D7 is going to create pressure then just
think no problems uh there's some lines
after here Queen H6 that the engine
might think is a little bit better but
the more they think it's just completely
fine so the engines were pretty adamant
take on C4 there's no actual problems
but what mvl did was hide the king first
which I think is a very human decision
and after Queen takes D6 he does have
this move which was played in the game
Rook C8 and tactically he is defending
things for the time being now I could
take on B7 with the bishop but I have
the move Knight takes C4 that's an
important resource it's the only move to
keep in the game but it's good enough
the idea is that if you take take I'm
hitting the Knight on A5 and your Bishop
on B7 is hanging however even in this
position after Knight takes E4 Rook
takes B7 the engines do think that after
Rook everyone you could claim a little
bit for the white side why because
there's this majority that could create
a pass Pawn pretty quickly and for the
time being this bishop on F6 is not
great yes if you ever get to play E4 for
free great your Bishop is open if you
put your Bishop on D4 that's also great
but none of those things are going to be
happening anytime soon so white could
use the stamp P to try to establish some
dominance on the light squares go Rook
D5 go rookie for play H3 put play play
B3 put everything on a light Square so
that this bishop can't attack it and
only eventually start pushing and
marching the pawns off the board while
harassing this weakness on A6 so perhaps
a little bit of a better end game for
Levon if he chooses to go Bishop takes
B7 another possibility to do so is to
take stakes and of course you complete
Bishop takes B7 and transpose but also
possible I think is to play something
like Rook C1 and try to hold on the pawn
to the pawn that way now if you play the
move B3 in this position you're gonna
have you're gonna run into a little bit
of trouble because it looks like I'm
taking on B7 next move and B3 simply
solidifies that pawn on C4 unfortunately
if I if black defends The Pawn With The
Rook on B8 and you're not allowed to
take on B7 anytime soon you start
realizing that this night it's not
that's not very comfortable doesn't have
any scores back and white black has a
direct threat of Bishop E7 Bishop B4 and
the Knight would be captured and it's
almost Unstoppable so you don't have the
time to play B3 you do have the time to
play Rook C1 but uh I think Levon is
going to go for the end game with Bishop
takes B7 makes sense to me thank you
very much Alejandro and turning our
attention to the game a very key game in
the grand Chester standings uh between
Jan and Fabi uh we left it at this point
Queen B1 Queen B6 Peter and the players
pretty much
um got into a bishops of opposite color
ending but Ianna was the one enjoying
the extra Pawn is that meaningful Peter
it's interesting that he chose this over
the position with the bishop against
Knight I understand that this way the
difference between this and what we were
discussing earlier is twofold uh this is
clearly just an opposite color Bishop
ending but also the the the passer is on
the a file instead of the C file right
because in those positions the A3 Pawn
was falling and the sheep on was the one
that would survive and honestly I think
Fabi holes this very very comfortably
I'm a little bit surprised if we just
fast forward to what they have on the
board right now
uh because I think well it's very
difficult to talk about this end game in
any kind of a meaningful fashion until
something increase starts happening yes
this position specifically this position
I do have one question here uh Jan quite
quickly played Bishop B6 here I will be
playing Bishop D6 if we are to discuss
this seriously I think the bishop kind
of needs to be on before in particular
if we can lock out the Rook from the
game he's played Bishop B6 instead which
I don't quite understand because it
really isn't doing there very much and
also it allows exactly what Fabi played
quite quickly which is Rook C3 Rook C3
and G7 G5
and now that the pawns are starting to
come off on the king side it just feels
like really nothing whatsoever for white
agreed uh just again right here uh
I I like I like the the way you were
saying like if you could speed it up but
I was thinking about Scotty and Star
Trek Captain I'm giving it her all she's
got you know uh Bishop D6 makes a lot of
sense yeah well I guess Stakes takes
Rook G4 or something and then put it
Rook D4 yeah yeah because I was about
five years before it's an improvement
it's an improvement I I still wouldn't
like to claim that this is much better
for wise or anything like that I think
it remains a draw even here I don't know
even maybe I don't have to put it on the
keep it on the fourth rank like 25 full
of budgie five or something
but uh what Jan got in the game okay now
we have some kind of an explanation at
least because after take Stakes he's
played Bishop d8 okay and he's trying I
guess to follow it up with Rook C5 okay
and weirdly I think what actually has
more like if you imagine let's make some
stupid moves here King G6 okay Rook C5
and in particular very very stupid move
Rook takes A3 here which I think he's
never getting played Rook G5 King H6
okay I think this one while probably
also drawn actually offers white Morrow
winning shot within one upon yeah with
the one with the outside passer on the a
file because the outside passer on the a
file is on A3 right the way the pieces
are it probably never crosses even to a
four let alone A5 yeah the blockade yeah
because the blockade is too strong right
and here the one we have on the screen
on the analysis screen right now the
king is weak H5 Pawn is weak potential
yeah there is definitely like you can
actually get into some trouble with your
king safety here if white let's say
manages to play it on King H4 F4 F5 give
you a check from the sixth rank like
push your King backwards I still suspect
that like black plays Bishop B8 here and
holds after King H4 for instance that it
might be more uncomfortable but I think
this one I would be I would be sweating
a little bit more as black compared to
the one we have on my screen so let's go
back to Bishop d8 and try not to get
this position right
um well you can do that by playing G4
yeah I'm not that happy I like G4 I
think very clearly it goes a 4 for yeah
and then if white gets some kind of a
setup with King H4 and G3 maybe it
becomes legitimately uncomfortable what
I would like to investigate is can I go
H4 check okay I'm assuming King H2 okay
and I wonder ah Rook takes F3 is a check
I wanted to play G4 here
but we can take on H4 and when you catch
ngf the bishop is not actually hanging
because I mean it is hanging but we're
not I have a Tempo yeah we don't get to
take a ship and the the you know quote
unquote fun thing about that end game uh
if like even the final position like
let's let's get there again
the thing about this is that maybe even
this is not strictly speaking winning
and I have seen people defend those just
not because it's not even like not
strictly speaking winning it's just kind
of a draw right yeah I mean you you kind
of a draw I mean because it's the wrong
Groupon yeah so also I mean the the the
the a rook uh I mean sorry the a pawn is
of the wrong color which obviously
creates an additional layer of security
for black you might even want to be
running to the other side King E6 and
this is in the scenario where we
blundered a full Pawn Yeah Yeah uh yeah
actually I actually agree with this just
put it on C6 and wait for white to play
G4 and then take twice and then take
twice but drop your Bishop but on the
other hand you can imagine losing this
because like if white plays it cleverly
and uh never really gives you a chance
to uh to save the bishop yeah
um so yeah
um
you can also hang on we can we can go
Rook a funnel okay five would not be a
good idea yeah apologies apologies for
that yeah um and again uh just to say
King uh Rook C5 I think it's Rook C5 I'm
pretty sure this is what he's planning
or maybe Rook d36 check but that looks
less can I borrow a page from what you
previously wanted oh yeah maybe now yeah
because now there's no Rook takes F3
check yeah yeah this may this makes a
lot more sense actually yeah just do
this
combining those two ideas that that you
were saying yeah
um so this is uh uh a pawn up ending for
Napo uh play on to uh
uh play for two results if you will uh
and I wanted to go if you don't mind to
the uh remaining game uh there we have
in the game of Ali Reza and Shaq all the
pieces on the board oh yeah this is by
far the most exciting the most sort of
alive game position of of all the games
we have today let's see what happened
after we left we left it right about
these places
suggested by Alejandro and I think the
biggest issue with the movement ibd7
here is that you obviously would like to
put it on E5 but you cannot currently
because you need to keep the connection
between The Rook on E8 and the pawn on
e4 at least for the time being saruk A1
and here
um shark played A5 B5 Bishop D4 which is
a very concrete idea and Bishop D4 does
sort of generate the idea of playing uh
for me A5 is not in my database so they
it may be a novelty A5 I don't think I
think they've been playing on their own
for a while okay honestly I don't think
they know what's going on necessarily
it's a rare enough position that I don't
think they're aware of previous practice
the opening's not quite over yet uh
White Hazard Castle connected his Rooks
but after B5 Bishop D4
it feels like a three result game oh
yeah absolutely it's a very very sharp
position uh very difficult to judge I I
generally like my first thought in these
types of positions whenever I see a
position specifically from this
variation like my initial thought is why
it must be a little at least a little
bit better and then I start looking at
moves and I realize I don't know how to
back that up right that's just a gut
feeling which very often will be
incorrect here I've sort of learned to
accept it that my my calibrations are
generally quite a bit off because I like
how this looks basically like my my
aesthetic sense here is so pleased by
you know the quirkiness of the white
setup that I I just want to be
avoided for it yeah right for me I'm not
rewarded I'm not I'm not a big fan of
this Knight on E3 if I could put the
Knight on D6 or something like that may
I give a a shot I mean I understand
Bishop F2 isn't it doesn't seem to be
working yet yeah but for the moment
and now you're now you're forcing me to
and now I want to go
and the whole point is the desirable
King F2
oops yeah that is I think we're moving
that from E3 is generally very much
fraught with uh with danger oh it's got
danger written all over it but danger is
our middle name no it's not no it's not
uh What uh
Salinas Peter yeah 94 exists yeah I
couldn't refute it off the bat like I
wanted to start with by taking on B2 and
going from there why not yeah it might
be it yeah but you can take on a six and
take on YouTube with the Knight I will
have compensation I will have plentiful
compensation there if that's the best
way it has I'm going for this position
very very happy like Bishop 5 or Knight
of three check Knight D4 actually
yes yes I thought neither three was kind
of empty because King F1 but before is
not empty very very good okay so 93 to
C4 isn't to try uh like you say you want
a reward for your nice understanding
your strategic my first my first
instinct was bc6b69 A4
CBC night A4 trying to get rid of that
bishop and I think your knight off well
I mean it has a very nice Square on C5
for the future it might return to C3
white with yeah exactly and then I
realized it looks weird but the 65
supports everything we have not at the
moment we have not actually gotten rid
of the bishop on D4 because Bishop d4c
takes D4 is extremely unattractive we're
never doing that uh extreme yeah and we
also have developed the bishop on C8 to
a degree because it will go to a six now
very happily yes yes and put pressure on
the E2 pawn and this is where I got
stuck because that was my that was my
first reaction I was kind of happy for
three seconds right and then I saw c65
and I stopped being happy yeah bcbc
makes some sense you're splitting the
pawns but here again you're kind of you
made you got to make a decision with
your king one day I mean you got a
castle uh Peter yeah absolutely so yeah
or maybe you prefer in that case just to
keep the tension for another
apply yeah can we
keep ah no we can't right I mean we can
but if we Castle here if we just say the
time has come from for us to do
something about our King position I
think Knight E5 becomes playable
but maybe it's then we can go like take
Stakes like day four because C5 maybe is
no longer no longer on the agenda yeah I
don't know it's it's such a difficult
position to judge properly
even like even if we accept that we've
ruined our structure here a little bit
and we take on the two we gobish Basics
it is such an unclear position
Rook at V1 and then perhaps it's just
simply h7h5 or something and go for it
and
fun fun fun stuff it's a very very
exciting uh exciting game in progress
I'm whoa and the move he made what uh
Rook D1 to B1 now that that was deep
that is very deep and also you have to
say that if you play Rook D1 move 14 and
then you sort of correct yourself on
move 16 here with the mobile B1 things
are probably not going exactly to plan
uh right
um it might still be okay but Alejandra
what do you got to say about them apples
Rook D1 to B1 that that caused us to
stop that's a weird Apple yeah sir I'm
not really sure about that one I would
understand it if he played it in one
move but I don't understand why he
decided that in this particular moment
he wanted to correct his Rook the moment
move Castle you guys were mentioning
it's just fine I don't see any problem
with that I understand that with those
ghosts of dingler and getting mated must
be hunting players that play this
variation but some at some point who got
a castle I just want to ask you
something because I feel like in
particular the move the move Ali
resonate here I think is an indication
that it's not really the getting mated
as in Madrid is what is worrying him
it's Bishop takes C3 followed by C takes
B5 in this position Bishop takes E3 yeah
but but it's just horrible right I mean
for a number of reasons I would assume
let's go through what the engine thinks
I mean you could just take on C3 take on
B5 and like every move is a little bit
better for white D3 is fine you just get
the compensation you get the two Bishops
this bishop is just a monster in this
position and specifically the engine
thinks Queen C7 is very strong because
the queen binds this Knight on D7 it
doesn't allow it to go to B6 it doesn't
allow it to go to E5 this queen is very
hard to actually kick out of C7 because
you don't have the movement E5 as it's
controlled by this Knight on E3 and of
course without this Knight moving The
Bishop's not moving and nobody's coming
to C8 so this specifically is very
dangerous for the white uh for the black
side and after Castle I was trying to
take a look over some of the variations
that you guys were looking at sure H5 is
a move let's say that this is something
that could be worrisome Knight f8 is
another top engine move and I was trying
to think what happens here in this
position dangerous thing that takes
takes Queen A4 is good
Queen A4 is a clever move Queen A4 is a
very nice move taking advantage of the
fact that this Knight is overloaded what
does that mean if you play the move C5
notice how this Knight is defending the
pawn on e4 and it's defending the Rook
on E8 it can only do one of its jobs at
the same at a time if I take only four
here with my Bishop I attack the queen
and I attack The Rook on A8 and you
don't have the possibility to take here
because this is just Checkmate in one so
Queen A4 is clever the engine is also
thinking that somehow
some way Knight takes E4 is actually
possible in this position because some
crazy tactics you would think that this
loses
because after Queen takes B2 you have
Knight F3 check right this X-ray on the
queen on B2 but the engine's thinking
because they're engines that after D4
you get your piece back with a slight
Edge I think that's crazy this is
actually an exchange sacrifice if you
count it
which can kind of explain why somebody
wouldn't want to look at this but again
after Rook D1 and B takes C6 you are
getting a lot of initiative enough
actually for a slight Edge the line kind
of continues black actually has to give
the exchange back so but let's not get
back down on that because we do have the
move Rook B1 already on the board now I
don't think it presents a direct threat
so you can still play a move like H5
softening up the king side hoping the
white plays H4 and getting more squares
but I like the move C5 in this position
I don't see anything wrong with it this
bishop is now cemented on the Square D4
which is a great thing to do for black
and you can even now consider to play B6
Bishop B7 you can consider it to play 95
in a nicer way so I like the move C5 the
engines really hate this move for B1 by
alireza very mystifying decision on the
board yeah no I like the move C5 as well
Rook B1 uh too deep for me yeah not a
fan not a fan uh jumping back to our
Marquee matchup between our two leader
years of the competition Hans and Wesley
when we left it we left it just around
these parts and we thought it was in
White's interest to expand with h2h4
Hans agreed yeah unless they reacted in
a very concrete fashion because Knight
H5 actually introduces the idea of F7 F6
into the game right so you do have to
find a way to deal with the very very
immediate threat of F6 uh Sora catching
a bishop 25 it's currently ran out of
squares right I'm not sure what the
correct reply is I've been kind of
trying to
uh figure out what would my like in a
Blitz game what do I play here I still
don't know
um yeah I mean exactly you you you
you're inclined towards moves like
Knight G4 and night but then you have to
calculate open up the E file sorry but
now you have to calculate 94 F6 it looks
very scary there are checks and we have
opened up right our position to some
tactics along the E5 file but like what
tactics exactly do I play something yeah
crazy here and then I have to look at
Bishop before there's a lot of other
things yeah every five doesn't
necessarily lose but there's also as yes
absolutely correctly pointing out the
moment we go Rook G1 we're open
ourselves up to those and this isn't
exactly what we bargained for when we
were playing h2h4 expansion and honestly
I'm not sure black takes I think I think
now blood gets very satisfied by the
fact that Bob White mispositioned all of
those pieces which is called Queen D7
here
f66 for black without the light Square
Bishop I think is pretty decent we have
some squares behind it and like Queen D7
Knight hd7 if you need to be now maybe
we will take a look with the green
Nissan maybe I will take on a fortnite
move if it's still there yeah truth be
told I I feel like I kind of rescued
myself it's almost like like I misplaced
my pieces a little especially the bishop
of four yeah let's look at the Double
Take on that Forum if we don't mind yeah
like e probably yeah yes I guess not G2
takes a four because otherwise I need I
I need to play H4 H5 and so yeah and we
go Queen D7 here I suppose right
attacking the G4 Square
yeah I mean I'm a bit worried about a
four or five but maybe I shouldn't be
because those enemies will be fine right
just Queen takes black probably doesn't
end up winning the position but black
definitely doesn't lose it right yeah oh
no but I I I'm worried about my own King
I I queen takes F5 fine but maybe yeah
you could also we could also do this for
sure I don't
um I don't know if this is what white
wanted when he yeah so this whole
Direction
I'm very curious questions very curious
uh and uh oh sorry this is this is the
current president I just I just don't
know what I want here with white I would
be I would be kind of uh
uh this is where you you spend a I think
a long long time
kind of engage engaging your options or
alternatively maybe you could uh sort of
predict that this might happen and you
might have an answer at the ready when
you play H4 Knight H5 right because
black really if you go back to the
position after h2h4
it's not very much that black can do
there so Rook Knight H5 might actually
be in your field of vision simply
because you know black has to move
something yes
Bishop 6 is not a move any Bishop
anywhere really is not a move because
the pawn D5 might become weak right 97
is unplayable for similar similar
reasons Knight has just come from E4 so
it's not going to go back to E4 so it's
basically Queen D7
I think and then perhaps Knight H5
because simply you you run out of other
things to consider exactly so uh
it's possible to kind of for you know be
be
aware of this and have an answer but I
think Hans has been thinking for a while
in this position so maybe he was
slightly taken by surprise by that
choice Alejandro what do we think
ah top move for the engine replying
Knight H5
B4
huh
yeah B if four of course yeah I guess
the idea is to like play Queen B3 and
just give up that piece somewhere but
yeah
Jesus
takes place
computer very strong yeah I mean this is
kind of a crazy line
wow E3 and if it does say that if you
take only five you're worse
take only five night takes D5 and the
attack rages I mean I guess
guess I mean I wouldn't guess that
actually from saying the position but I
have an engine
um yeah King ha Knight hd7 the thing is
you do get two pawns right yeah I mean
you can see how there's plenty of
convincing there's plenty of play I
think the more you look at it if you get
to this position yeah you start
realizing that yeah there's a lot of
threats I mean the moment I move my
knight the queen will be hanging to The
Rook after I take on E5 this king is
pinned yeah there's a lot of comp there
it's just coming up with the idea it's
kind of yeah difficult I think yeah
before might not be in your field of
vision at all yeah like you you can get
there simply through you know the
realization so okay so what's the second
best choice then C takes D5 and B4 okay
uh is there a plus button
is there a plus button you could click
there so that you can get a third option
I I do I do have one hey where'd it go
the CPU lines here three yes that is
pretty funny we're fine trying to find a
bad move please not necessarily a bad
move but like we've established yeah
we've established before is a good idea
here but I'm just wondering like you
don't see it and it's very very possible
I agree like what what are the other
choices and uh I thought it was going to
be no it's 9g2 okay so okay so you you
kind of have to back down and and
liquidate into that as we've established
I think black is completely fine there
no black is better public is better I
feel better it's beef it's finding cd5
B4 with one combination or the other or
being worse I see and by the way uh once
again to our audience thank you so much
for joining us and sharing your day with
us tell tell your friends where you're
hanging out but we opened the show with
this whole concept that we are in the
eye of a chessic hurricane the
withdrawal of Magnus Carlson is really
going to set the social media Blaze and
it's news all across the world but we
did want to inform you that Hans will be
joining us our show and if there are any
questions that you would like to ask him
or ourselves you can certainly do that
through our tweet at U.S at STL chess
club on Twitter or you know all the
chats as far as I know exactly not not
by us but but yeah Anastasia as taking
care of all of that and she will feed
your questions to Hans as well as
ourselves that will be certainly coming
up in the broadcast I have to say
frankly Peter that with the on on B3 my
my vision was was blocked I mean if I
put the pawn back on B2 of course yeah
the first thing I started thinking about
is hey you put your knight on A5 I'm
going to take and go Queen B3 for some
reason I didn't have that on my radar
easy to miss extremely easy to miss and
I uh while you were talking there I was
clicking a little bit because I wanted
to check uh how long of a think this is
so far he's been for Hans for Hans he's
been thinking for uh 16 minutes so far
maybe 16 and a half so it's been a
reasonably long uh long time uh in the
tank understandably so because the
position has become suddenly very very
concrete and exactly you
me it really is a position in which as I
mentioned like I've we've been talking
about other positions but I have this
one on my screen like I'm I'm trying to
monitor all four games at the same time
just to see if anything interesting is
going on and I saw Knight H5 and like I
kept on staring at it and thinking like
what am I playing here and and coming up
coming up coming up entirely blank yeah
I just had no idea what I'm supposed to
do about the very very straightforward
thread above seven of six right so yeah
a very very understandable kind of a
pause there uh by Hans but and now I've
got to ask you and Alejandra now that we
know that B4 is legit and we really do
want to sacrifice a piece go ahead play
F6 make my day uh let me play Knight
takes D5 and my Pieces come alive you
Rook on the A8 your knight on H5 and it
begs the question can I just meet you at
the past and not necessarily go for F7
F6 yeah I was wondering about that as
well uh I assume there is now something
new in the position which white can try
but I'm not entirely sure it's Rook D1
it just thinks here you guys are playing
the top line of the engine oh and it's
just going Rook D1 and the engines think
that the moment that you probably have
sex you're just weakening too many
things on the e-file and eventually
because of Knight takes E5 ideas that
you're not really scared of the move F6
now not easy to foresee of course this
is according to the engine is just equal
I'll go through the variations a little
bit here Queen D7 you can play F6 it's
not enough it's not actually an issue
you just shouldn't take on E5 directly
Rook here Rook D1 and the move F6 right
I know it's difficult especially V8 I
was wondering
but it uses the fact that the Rook is
overloaded right and I guess Rook takes
ba Knight takes D5 is obvious that
there's too many things hanging on this
side of the board you can still play
bishop f8 and be okay or you could start
with the move Bishop f8 in this position
and still be okay F6 is now starting to
become more and more and more of an
issue but okay you hear you have Knight
G4 now you have Knight takes D4 tactics
to calculate because the queen is
attacking this Knight on G4 tons of
things to consider so it's not a not a
miracle that Hans is taking 18 19
minutes I think at this moment it's a
really serious thing oh yeah and uh
considering this has only move 20 uh and
this is extremely unlikely to be the
last difficult question he has to ponder
in this game we might be headed towards
an interesting time travel potentially
because tell me about the clocks yeah
what is it he's down to 35 minutes
against more than an hour for Wesley and
there's still 20 moves to make so wow
yeah this is suddenly uh you know it's a
very quiet line of the Petrov in general
but it's no longer really all that quiet
I think this this has a very good
potential of becoming uh uh it feels
like the tension is getting ramped up
with each and every move uh Rook Knight
H5 is really uh caused some real
questions for one absolutely set up and
an interesting strategic idea there
being demonstrated move after move in
the uh our onion mvl game
and after some prolonged thought
actually uh let's spent like 16 minutes
on Mr takes B7 searching for more
clearly because this is always a default
option and now rook fe1 and what mvl is
doing here I think is very very
instructive because generally speaking
you know it's an end game uh being
played on two flanks so the bishop
should be stronger than the Knight like
in in theory in a vacuum the bishop
should be stronger than the Knight here
but the bishop is very very locked out
on F6 right by its own Pawn on E5 plays
the movie 5d6 and we're in business and
then yeah black maybe is instantly
slightly better yeah and what MBL is
doing here is he is saying I actually
kind of actively need to get rid of it
so that the bishop plays right and go
ahead take my e-pawn yeah take my e-pawn
what I assume is going to be a little
bit better after Knight takes C5 but the
bishop suddenly starts to breathe and we
I I'm guessing we go Rook B5 or a6a5
straight away I don't want to allow 97
though I think we can excuse to preserve
to uh sidestep before so let's go rugby
five and then let's say 93 A5
is a monster uh a 5a4 if allowed in a
favorable circumstance will generate a
lot of counter play and so you want it
yeah I think 54 is natural but then I
don't know maybe room D5 or something
like this and just
it's very often this is quite quite
manageable for for the side defending
with against an extra Pawn in positions
like this because the bishop is so
active you still of course I think be
quite generally speaking right why it is
but but I very much like what mvl is
doing and I wanted to highlight it
before left takes only five or before
left perhaps even says no like you can
go Rook before here and claim and claim
no I don't want I don't want that
particular point I want to play Rook D6
and then I don't know King b2a3 A4 or
whatever right uh and I very badly want
your Bishop to be dead
exactly we'll see what he comes with by
the way by coincidence yesterday on my
free day I spent the day re
um listening to a podcast for on the BBC
about the deep blue Gary casparov and in
that second match deep blue declined
capturing the pawn and that threw Gary
and sizzy and uh that you you didn't
take the extra pawn and allow Gary's
Bishop to open up the board rookie 4
would be
a pretty high-class match by the way has
been played by he's a high cost player
no sooner did we mention that Rook E4
would be actually be a pretty darn good
so so we have a kind of an unusual
situation here where we're playing an
end game this is not a some kind of a
middle game exactly with attacking
threats it's just that both players I
think correctly actually value the
activity of the F6 Bishop at least for
the time being higher right than a full
Central Pawn because we can see that if
white is just left to boringly improving
honestly I don't think I'm touching the
king side you don't like I like it
somehow age 64 but I was going to say
boringly improving the position with our
Rooks I rookie 4 Rook D5 King C2 h3g4
maybe that pawn will just fall on its
own accord and much more favorable
circumstances yes I think so I think uh
this will be very interesting to watch
in the meantime
and I'm expecting a move more or less
immediately because thinking for like 20
minutes taking on G5 and then thinking
again is not how you should be managing
your time and as as we know from
Alejandro uh White's best and maybe only
move not to get a disadvantage is to
play the move B for beef if b3b4 before
opening up the the square for the queen
so that we can capture the pawn on D5
sacrificing a bees and Wesley did you
say has an extra hour
he's got a more human approach 92. and I
think the reason that he inserted C
takes D5 in this position is because I
don't think that he'll Retreat to the F4
Square I think that after F6 he's
actually eyeing this possibility here on
on B8 yeah and if you were to play
Bishop F4 you would have done it without
taking I think so yeah and if you play
Bishop B8 you do it this way now it's
still a mess here there's a lot of
possibilities for Wesley for example he
could just move the bishop right still
ask the bishop where this is going uh
defense the Knight on E6
uh I think right only move here is G4
you have F Force officially defended uh
you could take on B8 but after G takes
H5 actually there's a lot of pressure on
the G6 square and if you Retreat Bishop
G3 then it's unclear exactly who this
expansion favors you do have a lot of
weaknesses behind you notice that this
bishop is annoying because you want to
fight for the E file you just can't do
it this bishop is just uh targeting the
E1 Square consistently I like coming
with the move Rook C8 I personally like
to move Queen D7 even better just to
Target the G4 Pawn in the long run so
this still looks a little bit worse for
the white uh for the white side after F6
Bishop B8 you could just go crazy
Wesley's not going crazy Wesley is not
that type of player and go King F7
defend this way invite a sacrifice like
Rook takes C6 which might be playable G4
also playable the idea is that in this
case you take with the queen you go here
and you go Knight F4 and somehow because
of the King on F7 defending the pawn on
G6 you'll have the time to bring the
queen into the king side this might be a
way of playing it might be actually be
very strong but do you really want to
expose your king that way what's up to
Wesley to evaluate because it is
tempting to just go for the slight
positional Advantage with F6 Bishop B8
and then uh immediately defend this
Knight with Bishop B4 right and
Alejandro F6 Bishop F4 did we like Queen
D7 or did we like capturing no we take
twice no we take we definitely take we
take with the E Knight of course uh you
don't want to take with the G point you
take here you take take and the thing is
that if you had the time to play F5 and
H5 I think maybe you got some counter
play but Queen D7 is just putting a
kabash on pretty much everything if you
play F5 you have to remember that after
Bishop D6 you're not running my Pawn
Queen G4 is too strong you can't allow
this queen yeah my idea was to play Rook
D1 here and start trading I understand
that the F5 Pawn is gone but like I I
think those end games shouldn't be that
bad but maybe it's not an end game maybe
you actually keep the pieces on the
board you keep the pieces on the board
you play GH and which king is weaker and
the way that we analyze this is the
power of the pieces how easy are they to
Target the opponent's king and even
though at the beginning they look about
equal the more you analyze the position
it the clearer it is the black has a
clear plan to attack the king in
particular in my opinion King h8 Rook G8
Queen G7 and then start hitting this guy
and this bishop is already in a good
diagonal whereas this Knight it's
controlled by this Pawn on F6 so how
does it join The Fray if this bomb was
on H3 I could say Knight H4 Knight F5
but it's not an H3 it's an H4 it's in
the way so I don't think that this is
acceptable for the white side the end
just actually give a bigger Advantage
than I would have thought uh they give
one minus 1.6 so difficulties here for
Hans if uh Wesley goes for the move F6 I
just don't expect him to go Bishop F4
it's such an ugly position I think we'll
go Bishop yes I think so as well by the
way I'd like to turn our attention to a
uh
to the game between for Rouge and Shaq
we left it we left it right here uh rook
in fact sorry let me do this after after
Rook B1 C5 a move that we really like
just cementing the bishop and asking
white well why did you spend so much
Tempe on the queen side uh age for again
uh Ali Reza is basically saying I'm not
comfortable putting my king on the king
side H5 why not city five but this one
random ran into some tactical ideas here
which takes up to the point is after
King takes of two which I assume has to
be played right we go queen of five
check right and no no
Knight takes E3 simply defends we go
Queen F5 check and the Knight on D5 is
attacked if it goes to F4 which is the
intention of H4 yeah then suddenly 43
will work because I think C3 is no
longer available so I guess we go King
G1 Queen takes D5 and think about our
life but then we've sacrificed upon food
exactly we still have we still have the
bishop bear D3 he takes D3 question mark
question mark
D3 e takes D3 question mark question
mark I don't know uh it doesn't feel
lost for white or anything like that
maybe Rook F1 F4 is an interesting idea
here okay but then I've got to get mine
we can use the other Rook uh but then
the other one is stuck on H1 a little
bit uh yeah I thought maybe Rook F1 here
but I I do have time to play B6 Bishop
B7 which is extremely important in my
mind
should be seven yeah because I think if
the E4 Pawn Falls white is suddenly
extremely happy and I also really don't
like the idea of playing of seven and
five no because then the position of on
board yeah I think with the bishop on B2
I would like that pawn to eventually be
on F6 blunting the bishop but I think B6
Bishop B7 sort of stabilizes the
position remains kind of unclear but if
black stabilizes here yeah D3 I wanted
to go like Queen D6 or something yeah
Queen Davidson yeah and ask you if you
like you can take but then I will
establish a blockade like I will play
f695 through kg8 and I will claim that
this is a very very healthy position
from black crime wow
um
but my impression is blunder I'm not
sure I don't think you blunderbishop
Texas too I don't think like this is
such an a constant threat really because
he's not moving and does he have an
option
yeah that is a good point yeah
if it hadn't been a blender if it was if
he had been expecting the move Bishop
takes F2 well he doesn't treat it like
if you love me G3 you were just lost
right you guys take it yes that's a very
understandable blunder right you
probably
if you put it on your board Bishop takes
F2 I do um and then you think you have
Knight F4 here right exactly there's a
thing you have Knight F4 in your mind
you probably think you're completely
fine and then you realize that that E3
you had that uh you know the combination
of those two threats is very powerful
yeah and I I could see there on on
Alejandro's board that yeah my attempts
to make this playable for White against
best play probe they're going to be
unsuccessful yeah and again just because
I am a pond grubber I do
[Laughter]
who is doing some
um post-mortem and somebody was making a
suggestion no yoking um
on the board
and uh okay uh let let's go down that uh
line we looked at oops sorry not that
line kg1 wants more a little bit more
seriously I still like Rook of 104. I
don't like spending a lot of Rook F1 I
think spending a whole Tempo on King H2
is just going to make Black's life so
much easier in particular because 95
becomes a topic because Knight G4 check
will be such a an unpleasant threat I
think the King has to stay on G1 for now
and I still very much like my B6 Bishop
B7 I think that's the way to develop
here
um somehow nothing wrong with that uh
as well yeah I was just like is can that
Knight somehow get to a better Square
than D7 and okay yeah so you're the pawn
grubber okay hold on uh uh you get in
you can and you might
the agent says there's more than one way
to get a decisive Advantage with black a
decisive Advantage yeah bordering on two
wow this is just one of them I mean King
actually went to E1 very interesting
yeah but Queen is one of them he's just
saying all right what's your threats
so not King to G1 excuse me I'm just
gonna go back a moment King to E1 on the
board yeah Queen takes D5 also played of
course because let's recover our piece
yeah I guess he goes with one here
exactly he he felt that the King on
jiwan wasn't much safer than anyone
anyway and uh Brooks on yeah I can see
how you prefer the one to the H1
honestly okay it does a little bit Fair
uh the the strangest part I was about to
suggest Knight f8 and Bishop F5 but can
we now uh go down I don't know I think I
really hate uh giving up the volume four
even though I understand let's say which
before we can still go like a knight of
Fate here and well I mean yeah yeah you
know I understand but uh for me uh
keeping the bishpanjuta restricted is a
far far bigger priority than any of this
like my My First Choice here would be
either B6 Bishop B7 or perhaps if we go
back one move yeah like I can actually
play Knight f8 instead of grenade too
you like that let's go with it I like
your your unless I blundered queen C3
Rook takes F6 but I don't think I have
yes you did I did yeah okay good did you
but then I unblundered it by mentioning
before
you caught yourself just a touch okay
all right uh guys we're gonna just take
a a short break with some very very
exciting chess still this is a good
round yeah this is a good round this is
great stuff we're going to see you on
the other side of the bridge
[Music]
welcome to the chess capital of the
United States
the St Louis chess campus in the heart
of the vibrant Central West End has
established itself as a premier Global
destination for chess and is comprised
of two unique non-profit institutions
the chess club and Scholastic Center of
St Louis is recognized as the top chess
facility in the world and plays hosts to
all major tournaments including the U.S
chess championships and the sinkfield
cup one of the strongest chess
tournaments globally
tournaments are broadcast online to more
than 150 countries led by an expert
commentary team of grand Masters
the chess club is an educational
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess with a specific focus on
bringing the benefits of Chess to
Children throughout the St Louis area
research shows children who play chess
exhibit improved analytical skills and
increased confidence the chess club is
highly engaged with the local community
bringing Scholastic chess programs to
more than 100 Schools providing hundreds
of classes each week
directly across the street from the
chess club is the World Chess Hall of
Fame this one-of-a-kind cultural
institution invites visitors to
experience chess in imaginative ways and
is home to the U.S and World Chess Halls
of Fame Cutting Edge exhibitions feature
rare historic chess artifacts paired
with world-class art Innovative
programming explores the intersection of
Chess art and culture
visitors can enjoy interactive programs
designed around the exhibitions and
monthly music in the galleries the World
Chess Hall of Fame is nothing you expect
and everything you love three different
Galleries and a premier gift shop
highlight the culture history and
creativity Behind The Game come visit
play chess leave enriched to learn more
about the St Louis chess campus visit
stlchesscampus.org
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
six of the singfield cup and plenty of
plenty of action of all on all boards
today with uh potentially for scoring an
important victory in a somewhat meh
going tournament for him right with the
black piece against but let's start with
the uh fight between the two leaders in
the game between uh Hans Neiman and
Wesley so and Wesley actually found this
entire sequence that Alejandra was
pointing out prior to the show going on
break but should be it did happen to
which Alejandro Wesley replied with king
of seven which is definitely one of the
better options here exactly specifically
with the idea that Wesley is now
demonstrating winterx B8 GH and Knight
F4 and this sequence allows black to
learn the queen on F4 now Wesley
basically has after HGH D1 which has
been played here
black has a draw on top at any point but
of course there's absolutely no reason
for for black to take it uh too early
you mean a Perpetual check whenever he
wants absolutely yeah the king can never
really go to H2 because that runs into
Bishop D6 check meaning that there's
absolutely no way for white to avoid the
Perpetual but white is dreaming of bike
actually giving their Perpetual yeah
please bail me out of my uh mess that I
put myself in however I want to say that
it's I think it's difficult perhaps
Alejandro will in in three seconds prove
me completely wrong but I'm wondering if
uh there's anything here that is much
smarter than some kind of an end game I
can play Queen G4 check protecting the
pawn on G6 which is actually kind of
important and after let's say king of
one
I can allow uh the entire trade like
Bishop D6 for instance yeah and
everything comes off the board and the
port on H4 is awkward right but then
again uh how big of an edge is this
because with only two pieces left on the
board
it feels that this is probably within
drawing margins so I'm wondering uh if
we go back to our current position on
move 28 if there is anything that is
significantly smarter because the the
pin along the e-file does not really let
us play something like rook h8 and try
to attack on the king side we can't
really ever play G6 G5 because that
allows Queen H7 check F6 F5 looks wrong
can you put more pressure on the e-file
let's say I I'm gonna try to release
yep I play
I don't know rookie seeks actually H5
maybe I've won the game
yeah because I stopped you for a check
yeah this was actually one of the
reasons why I play King once more the
desirable Rook G6 has a issue at the
very end there will be a rook takes E7
so it feels like maybe you just have to
either give the Perpetual if you don't
believe that end game is winning or uh
you have to pull can I play Queen G
again I agree with you wholeheartedly
this is so slow we start coming out of
the corner here somehow like rookie 6
perhaps right we just go have I
blundered something no I don't think so
right don't they well like H3 and then
Queen takes C6 yes yeah okay so let's go
rookie three okay very restrained of you
know let's try it let's try let's start
okay three Rook D7 and then yeah eight
move again I'm just looking to break the
pin so that I can play what you said
keep the pieces on the board
yeah no I'm I'm looking at my G1 because
if you take on H4 I can go Rook h3h7
check and this might be useful I was
thinking King E2 Rook G1 no you don't
that as well yeah Knight G1 come again
95 doesn't work right I'm just curious
Knight E5 chat groups f e I know you
have E4 yeah I don't think it works yeah
uh so what is the the preferred it's
just the end game guys on the board it's
just the end game nothing else is better
for black it's just the end game with
Bishop D6 you can start with you can do
it immediately you can you can also do
it immediately because mg4 is always in
our background right and we go to this
for Rook ending the pardon me that we
trade the four Rooks yeah and I mean in
the miracle uh give us a 0.8 only okay
it's not pleasant though I mean it's
it's yeah it's very unpleasant when you
think the king's gonna come to D7 yeah
I'm gonna play Queen E4 one day exactly
I think the way you lose this with why
does you allow a queen trade and then
let's say just as an illustration let's
play a little King E2 here okay black
goes King D7 okay we play I don't know
just just for oh for for argument's sake
yeah something like this yeah Queen E4
check Queen E3 maybe even okay we go
King E6 publish before just just to get
the least the least amount yeah
something like I don't know 92 Queen E3
uh continue three King F5
this line runs once again for our
viewers the worst this is just to show
just to show what I'm aiming for with
black okay and okay maybe here
specifically you hold by playing king of
three and then Knight f193 check thank
goodness yes but if you don't have that
resource and black gets just a tiny bit
more progress right it's from the game
over yeah yeah it's probably gaming in
fact I'm really afraid of Bishop Edward
Shack and Bishop takes D2 I shouldn't
neither one might be losing right
because neither one at least you have to
calculate now the final language before
checking a 3g5
and I say yes please let's play those
pun endings really is it that bad um it
could be I know I think 93 check here
without taking on G5 is a draw though
and then FG and I mean with the outside
passer maybe black doesn't make it
but if I didn't have that first yeah if
I didn't have that then maybe I'd be I'd
be significantly worried but we
understand exactly how black could uh
really trade force that Queen trade
under better circumstances but there's
more tactical stuff going on elsewhere
else where uh Alejandro what caught your
eye let's take a look at levon's game I
was talking to him during his tournament
at the FTX Cup in Miami only about a
week and a half two weeks ago and he had
this really tough position in during
this event I believe it was against Duda
and he wasn't able to fully find a good
solution but when it came for Duda to
give the final blow he didn't have the
time to find it and I talked to live on
about it after the game and he just
looked at him he smiled and said well
that's part of the strategy and he has
actually purposefully played very
quickly in recent times he's actually
done this very often during this
tournament during the FTX cup and during
a lot of rapid and Blitz events
including the St Louis rapid and Blitz
he just has sped up he's tried to make
this pressure not only on the board but
on the clock on his opponents and check
out what we have here that we still have
nine moves to make for mvl and he has
eight minutes left
eight minutes left versus an hour versus
an hour and six from live on now the
position is still very annoying he has
just take uh played Rook C7 uh Maxim
that is because there was a certain
threat of Knight D6 in this position
hitting the pawn on F on F7 this was
thanks to this move rookie one covering
the C1 Square so now 96 is possible you
can't play Rook C7 then because takes
takes a knight E8 will Fork the king and
the Rook so you're going to do something
about a rook d8 was a possibility rookie
it also possible he decided to go with
Rook C7 which is again a pawn sacrifice
you could take take and you still can
take on E5 there's nothing wrong with
that you even have less compensation
here than you did when you could have
taken the pawn
all the way back here
B3 Rook C7 and you could take on E5 now
allow Rook B5 the agents say that you've
improved your position as well you can
take on E5 in a slightly better way
because there's less Rooks and with less
Rooks comes less counter play A5 A4
would be a lot less scary you could go
for this and then the engines are trying
to defend this bishop against Knight but
it's not so clear to me that you
actually get there it is a full extra
pawn it is a pawn that I'm going to be
able to make pass very quickly yes my
knight is all the way down on E1 and
perhaps you get counter Play Just in
Time with the move Bishop E5 attacking
this Pawn on H2 and why is it so
important to attack this Pawn on H2 is
to force it to go into a light square
and that way the king can penetrate on
the darks course and start creating that
counter play perhaps this is what Maxim
is trying to accomplish but of course
nothing is compelling everyone to take
on the C7 and then on E5 and considering
how he has played the the rest of the
game I would expect him to decline this
Pawn sacrifice and just play the move
Rook D1 defend this Rook on D7 he he's
happy to see an exchange of Rooks
because the Rook 86 or Rook A7 or even
Knight D6 will allow him to put pressure
on all of Black's position now this I
think is what the more human attempt is
we'll see which one Levon picks but he's
still playing very well but more
importantly very quickly
thank you for that Alexandra that was a
very good point yeah and I noticed after
this move Rook F1 and the shack rear
upon meeting the furugia chakra game
um
22 minutes whoa I really liked your B7
B6 move especially when we saw Rook
takes F6 yeah he's gone Knight f8
he's gone Knight f8 wait I thought we
talked about this well not with him
that's fair and the funny part Alejandro
was just a moment ago when he was saying
I was talking to Lavon and I was like
what
in Miami
I was talking Knight f8 okay after Queen
C3 you might have to go Knight E6 then
but that's very shaky because this 656
looks very very dangerous yeah I don't
even want to like we're barely not just
getting straight up mated with Knight D6
but you like it's just I don't think you
ever play this no why there isn't it
and also like Bishop H3 or queen G6
followed by Bishop takes E4 like nobody
ever does this exactly Queen chat oh
yeah in particular yeah no we're not uh
we're not going here so I think after
Queen C3 you are just straight up forced
to go 96 you have Queen G4 but after
Queen D4 you just have a war send game
no but 96 yeah
it creates the idea of 94 but I can
still play Rooker 4 I think if you play
94 I will just play three and it has to
go back
so Rooker 4 kind of forces F5 and it's
becoming a train wreck because like the
bishop on B2 is then like going to be a
problem for for the rest of the game I'm
currently struggling to win the game out
right with white right but honestly even
G2 G3 well wait a minute because no
Queen takes A2 is not turning the tables
not right D4 is not turning the tables
yeah I thought Bishop H3 but I think
Rooker fate still holds things together
to a degree like you say it's a train
wreck that just barely is cleaning under
the rails yeah it's just a very kind of
a strange
don't like what Shaq is facing after
Queen C3 Alejandra are we missing
something that because Shaq's not just
gonna say here go ahead and get a mating
attack on me he's got something off the
queen C3 and apparently we do equalize
but how well the agent doesn't think
that he is lost but he does think that
he's destroyed his Advantage because of
this move Queen c396 and specifically
what Peter mentioned this move Rook F4
attacking the pawn on e4 now the edges
don't think this is that bad that you
can play the move F6 in this position
since Rook takes up six is just down the
tempo so that doesn't work and also
you'll have Knight D4 ideas uh but you
could play Bishop D7 and they're not so
worried of just blundering the E4 Pawn
you could for example Play Bishop takes
or Rook takes E4 and just move the queen
now I don't think this is what shock is
aiming for right I don't think that he's
playing all of this to play Bishop D7
but I'm not really sure what else he
could do because a move like F5 does run
into D3 immediately in this position
capturing and in an even more powerful
way on e4 and even if it wasn't like the
best way to capture the pawn it is
returning the pawn and I'm not so sure
what he's getting for it so I I think so
what was uh what was good after Rook F1
uh pretty much every move
Queenie sexifying A4 was fine B6 was
fine B6 was the strongest I think but
pretty much anything that was not
uh yeah and alireza doesn't spend very
much time uh and deliberating on Queen
C3 because it's clearly the right way to
play here exactly not allowing Bishop G4
and not allowing black to establish any
kind of control is very very clearly and
96 immediately played no no you don't
blunder you don't blame you don't
blunder yeah yeah I mean you don't
blunder Queen C3 it's it's an obvious
follow-up and I I'm expecting alireza to
Blitz outrook F4 as well it it feels
like a very important move and then it
will be a kind of a pivotal moment in
the game because
uh if shark has to just give up the pawn
on e4 here yeah it's not what you wanted
yeah and it's it's it's not an easy
decision to to come to not at all no not
at all
I'm just trying to think some Knight D4
business but it's always like three yeah
yeah exactly it does nothing right no I
don't I'm trying to figure out exactly
where his plan is but I'm I'm
having trouble yes yes uh we all are oh
boy
um yeah no I mean you could do this if
there's nothing better but I I'm just
trying to figure out how in particular
since as I say like a player like Shah I
don't think you miss queen C3 I don't
think he missed Rooker 4 either all of
those things kind of come very very
naturally you know you create a threat
of Maiden one then you are the most
important Pawn on the board which
currently blocks our Bishop on G2 all of
this is very very logical so you really
have to ask yourself why why was it so
important to play Knight of Fate when
there were other other ways of
development very much available yeah can
he be imagining that hey look uh yeah
I've opened up my kingdom a little bit
but when you play D3 and you follow it
up with de4 I've got I've got a nasty
surprise waiting for you down there I
mean it's it's pretty clear which side
is by far the better developed uh here
with the Rook 28th and the bishop on C8
still very much locked out of anything
right I don't think like he's a very
experienced just of course he knows he
knows that if only one is not really
going to that's not going to be a topic
right now you can sort of continue here
you can take on a two in this position
perhaps wait for okay one and then go
like Queen D5 Queen D4 back and hope
that this somehow holds but right
it's surprising to me because like it
feels like we've relinquished so much of
our control by by allowing Our Queen C3
and Rooker for that uh it's a bit of a
yeah I I don't know uh how he would come
to the decision compared to some of the
other positions he had to choose from
okay let me just play
I'll give it a shot okay
uh gift me upon uh oh you want to play
Queen B3 right so precisely no but you
can't right through K1 you've actually
lost the game already I was going to
play Knight takes F4 but yeah Queen Rook
a eight okay
yeah it's a full Rook I would say yeah
that's that that's that ends that idea
no I I think uh Alejandro and and his
you know trusted computer is probably
correct you probably don't play a five
at all because it just creates this
absolute monster on B2 you play
something like Bishop D7 I think the
problem with playing Bishop D7 or F6
yeah uh the problem specifically with
Bishop D7 is that you have to see that
after Rook takes E4 which appears to be
winning on the spot because we'll take
Secrets such a threat you can play Queen
F5 using the fact that this Rook on B1
is hanging and this is the only reason
you're not losing The Rook takes e66
straight away exactly and this gives you
a Tempo to perhaps play a six next move
or 94 next move or something right uh
Rooker Four Element time has been played
by Le Reza
challenge you know the surprise and yeah
this is a very important point for
fuchsia clear he is still very much in
the game but he needs to kind of
well it's very easy and it's such a a
moment when you get hit with the moves
like Queen C3 and Rook F4 you suddenly
have this feeling like oh my God I just
didn't see that yeah like bang bang bang
you lose the E4 Pawn but that's an
important point that you're making Peter
Queen F5 you you sidestep the killer
threat and then we we want to kind of
re-establish some control with either
putting the Knight on before or playing
of seven or six kind of uh minimizing
the damage I think that I think you
found it Queen F5 if you play the move
D3 could he in his mind that is to say
shakri are saying aha this is how I get
to your king yeah and listen to my king
this looks fantastic but Rook takes E8
is obviously uh yeah a bit of a helpful
movie yeah we shouldn't be making it
exactly but on the other hand wait a
minute yeah Queen G6 yeah perhaps we
play something like Queen D2 here and
introduce the idea of Bishop takes D4
also the queen might be more useful on
F4 here perhaps in this position on
Queen G5 or something just try to stream
G5 okay yeah because I think n games
will be fine for white with the bishop
pair another the bishop on G2 is back in
the game
and by the way the move Queen D2 also
dealt with a Potential Threat of the
loss of the B5 Pawn because Bishop takes
yeah I want to I want to be able to
challenge the Knight on D4 in the
meanwhile Rook f4 on the board yes
absolutely are what is the clock yeah
well I specifically wanted to look it up
yeah alireza is down to 21 minutes and
Chuck is on 35 and this is move 24. so
wow not a lot of time but they are kind
of quite far progressed into the game so
it's not really uh time trouble the
clock banging situation yeah but it's it
might come we'll uh over to you
Alejandro will catch your eye in the
Lavon game I just wanted to keep an eye
on this one because Maxine's time keeps
sticking down and Ticking down he's
currently down to three minutes and 15
seconds only a couple of moves made
since rookie D1 he did play the move H4
trying to pretend that H3 at some point
is a threat maybe it's not such a
pretense and now H3 played relatively
quickly by Levon and here you have the
position on the board and his clock
keeps taking down he must be so
uncomfortable with this position yeah
really what Lavon is doing really
reminds me very strongly of nepo nepo
was just like you know he throws his
opponent off of a rhythm and suddenly
before you know it says 40 minutes
versus four yeah it's it's absolutely
something that the you know the dope
players who are specifically like the
the the players who trust their
intuition very much and Nepal comes to
mind Vision I think most definitely in
his best years was entirely capable of
just playing on your time almost not
using his part his half of the clock
wasn't really being used very much
the first time I played bushy was uh
suddenly it was like Dubai 1986 and and
really I I I used three hours he used
one hour and the game was drunk and
after the game I was like you know I was
furious with my colleagues like I mean I
used three hours and the guy only used
just an hour and they said oh you should
be that's very good yes and you've got
to use the whole hour
one of my one of my warmest warmest
chess memories was I think it was in
Sofia in 2006 I played this round drop
in the the mtel Masters which were yes
uh which were going on yeah and I played
against Vichy and uh that was by that
point our internal Dynamic was very very
well established I occasionally would
get possessions I would never win them
right and I would lose some of them uh
well not the good position but the ones
that are not good I would lose like half
or whatever right uh and uh in that it
was a double round robin and with the
white pieces I can't remember what the
game was but with the black pieces we
played some very kind of a complicated
anti-martial and at some point Fisher
misplayed it and I I kind of understood
that opening reasonably well in those
years and I got a very good position
and for the first time in my life
I saw this should get down to below five
minutes and start making dashes on the
scoresheet
whoa respect and I I didn't win the game
because I never win games again but the
fact that yeah
I thought I thought I achieved something
that no that is an achievement an
achievement to be sure uh just bringing
up the game between Fabi and uh nepo on
my uh board we do have a little bit of a
repetition No it should be seven yeah uh
young declines the immediate repetition
there isn't it is it time to maybe try
to get the Rook
to
the ideal station in life behind the
pawn I'm curious about the idea of
playing yeah Rook D4 maybe is a good
idea yeah just because it also makes the
idea of playing G5 G4 so much stronger
because that would be just a threat of
mating too precisely with the root
controlling the G1 Square exactly your
G4 will be a much much more forcing in
fact just because of that point yeah I
was a little bit of 25 yeah I was a
little bit afraid to offer G4 because of
this and in this case I can yeah maybe
we can still play it right oh my gosh I
was going to play Bishop takes H4 well
then GF we had this yeah yeah we had
this and wow maybe G4 is actually play
playable immediately and if it is
I think in many many cases it will just
make a more or less immediate draw
frankly because right you can't really
allow G3 check without winning anything
because then Rook D4 D1 will become a
very very serious threat yeah so you you
I guess you take but then we can even
maybe just take with the bishop
and suggest that the way for you to win
the H4 Pawn here would be to take with
the bishop eventually and then I'll take
on A3 right right so you do it like yeah
this I'll take on A3 as you just about
so Roxy Five checking H6 and we should
be making a draw feels very close blade
of five okay if it feels wow when you
play the move F5 uh as fortunately would
tell me you know you have to play very
responsibly from now on because oh yeah
that long diagonal you're not closing it
anymore there's no more F6 in the
position and whatever it was D3 D3
played yeah and there is also recognized
that still like if he gives black a
couple of Tempe here to I don't know
play 94 Bishop B6 the shock will be you
know something the attack will be much
much harder to uh
to consummate
and uh yeah he's blowing up everything
he is not really paying any attention to
the pawn on E2 which I think honestly
you have sorry you have to take it not
because it's so such an important Pawn
right now but because you want to have
some trumps for the future because your
Center is about to disintegrate it
certainly is yeah so you kind of want to
have the the outside passer and the a
file for the end games right which you
know if you survive until the end game
it will be a very very useful thing for
you to have true so you're recommending
I'm taking your nature here just now not
not prefacing it with 43 still doesn't
do anything I think okay so I go back to
D5 here ga4 I go 24.
and this is where you're I mean I'm not
happy about any of this but no but maybe
we can play like this and and uh and
hope to be uh doing at least somewhat
okay
wow just sorry I I have something to get
this out of this position but I don't
think I don't want to trade Queens I
don't want to play Queen
check and all of his positions that's
fancy privacy for it's a It's Tricky but
I think white is simply better if you
take on before to be honest I think this
is not good for black whichever way you
take if you take with the Knight yes I
will have forced to give up one of my
Bishop there but look at the difference
between the vishpanjitu and the bishopon
C8 there after takes takes indeed it's
quite the difference indeed I mean the
the bishop is coming to the mighty
Square D5 you have d43 here but I think
of the bishop D5 check followed by E4
you are probably lost honestly like
you're forking the two King takes D3 or
Rooker three takes D3
yeah like I mean Alejandro they're only
out here uh Shack's F5 uh
uh he's playing with fire isn't he Shaq
has been playing with fire since this
move Knight f8 and just keeping only a
knight defending this G7 Square that's
Checkmate this is just not good for
shock he's turned a position where the
engines thought he had a decisive
Advantage with pretty much any move into
a position with a clear wide Advantage
so a very big reversal of rolls there
and you guys actually found the best way
for black to play
Queen takes A2 Rook A1 Queen D5 you take
here Queen D4 takes you really don't
want to take with the c Pawn because the
problem is that after Rook takes F5 is
played you're also hitting H5 right
among other things if I will follow at
some point releasing this Kraken on G2
and in this variation that you guys were
showing taking with the Knight then
again it's this bishop on G2 that makes
a huge impression D3 is not quite as bad
as you guys were analyzing it but what
else do you play Rook d8 Bishop F3 he's
five maybe yeah yeah rookie five runs
into the Rook takes D4 and you have this
check on d8 followed by Rook C1 taking
advantage of the pin on the eighth rank
this starts to become just absolutely
horrible for a shotgun I'm not really
sure where he's envisioning this game is
going to go because these three look
pretty forced and now I'm just really
curious on what he wants if you played
something like this
he might have thought that perhaps your
wife cannot retake but pretty much any
other good move is good and it's true I
cannot take on D3
but if I play Bishop D5 or something
like this I mean this is just collapse
right yes this looks wrong yeah you go
for this yeah yeah I don't think you go
for this like on on purpose so I'm not
really sure what he's calculated too you
know what Grandmaster is calculated
Envision where they think the game will
go with best play from both sides what
you expect your opponent to play which
position is shock envisioning he's going
to get himself into after he played the
move Knight f8 and I'm coming up short a
little bit because everything looks bad
for him strategically bad to play F5 so
he needs to somehow find a tactic to
justify it but I don't see it
truly it just looks like as uh Alejandro
expressed it very well a role reversal
took place there Ali Raisa I was in
trouble now he's in the driver's seat
returning our attention to our marqueen
matchup between our two leaders Hans
demon and Wesley so when we left it we
kind of anticipated all of the four
Rooks coming off yeah we did have this
position and once again Peter you'd
mention ideas of Queen to E4 and trying
to just simply bring this King I think I
think without the queen trade is going
to be very very difficult to uh to win
this for black Wesley for now has gone
which before why probably Place Queen C3
I would say it's slightly more active
than Queen D3 but I don't think Queen D3
is very wrong as well right I think
Wesley probably will shuffle for a bit
try to look for kind of an easy opening
and then eventually you have to start
offering Queen trades uh because
otherwise I think the queen on the third
with a knight on F3 protect everything
right well enough that you don't
actually have any kind of an uh easy way
he may as you suggest be just kind of
shuffling around waiting for more
opportune moment to play Queen E4 but
imagine we had taken the bull by the
horns and played this move Queen E4 uh
probably with or without B7 B5 I'm not
really sure I'm probably not touching
the queen side for now I think our
options are like white is never like
white has established probably the ideal
structure so white is not playing A5 why
there's not playing before so our
options are going to remain open for the
rest of the game okay so what do you
think of Queen E4 and this so again the
idea is just pretty much five right
right uh now should you take an E4 I'm
very worried though right g492 I play F5
you play Knights four I think and then
that's the whole point I think often I
see four first of all it's hanging but
secondly I think maybe even the pawn
ending is very poor
specifically because I get the player
five or four there right like 96 King D6
uh King into F4 is just kind of resigns
right oops because that thing gets
locked out that yeah gets locked out and
that looks terrible uh so I like for
white I think there will be very very
few positions where you can actually
take only four and survive so you were
here you are sitting there with Y trying
to
desperately trying to sort of keep shape
I don't know you play King G2 here or
queen C3 or something okay King did you
say G2 G2 okay but here the question is
maybe we can already start coming in
right King E6 looks weird but maybe we
can okay King six with the idea of maybe
taking and going king of five or going
or even maybe going in a fight with the
Queen's on it looks a little strange
like you say but if if you want to do it
why not slalom your way right up the
board you're doing great yeah I mean
it's a very very scary proposition with
white here because you're like you won't
have very many moves for the rest of the
game we do he did start however with the
move Bishop F4 and like you say it could
just be yeah so he was actually doing
something maybe quite clever Queen G3 I
think was chosen yes and he played Queen
H3 chick so I think his idea is to say
would you like to put the King on G1
where it's kind of locked out or would
you like to play King U2 and then I
think his point is specifically after
King it too oh King King but it doesn't
lose right King H1 yeah this is not made
it looks like like it's made but it's
not actually made
yeah or something yeah ah I mean yeah
but I don't know I don't know okay sorry
but you were you were somewhere else
normally of course you're looking into
like King G1 is not a very comfortable
thing to do and then we go Queen E6
check
yeah okay and then we can go somewhere
and we go Queen E4 and maybe we want
some Tempe your Bishop magically
transfer from D6 to F4 so there is no
Knight D2 after the queen trade I like
that and and now after Queen C3 we still
have to look for improvements because
now with the like I can't go King E6
here because Quincy church just drops us
back but maybe we can go via the other
side I'm trying to figure out if there
is anything particularly wrong with like
going King G7 King H6 King H5 King G4
uh and uh slip away yeah this is not
this is not a very nice position to have
specifically against Wesley because this
is exactly the type of a game that
Wesley wins oh he loves this stuff what
he did with that I mean that game that
he won just by little little incremental
Improvement actually maybe slightly
unfair because against Fabi I think
Wesley played about as ambitiously as he
as he plays with white the opening was
kind of symmetrical ish but it was still
a very topical line I've actually
discussed it with some other players
here and apparently it's exactly what
Wesley played against Fabian net round
three was very much on the radar of a
bunch of people fertilizing the Petrov
right now uh and then uh and then he
played actually quite I think quite
ambitiously he won a pawn where he was
given this this option that he converted
very nicely but today is the absolute
model Wesley game yeah you get some very
solid opening prep in and then your
opponent makes a tiny mistake and you
get the free roll yeah on a good day you
win but you never lose yeah and those he
wins very very often because he's one of
the best in the world at doing that
we're seeing Wesley at his nearly
Flawless best Alejandra over to you what
cut your right
shock is collapsing collapsing he played
Knight D4 we analyzed this position and
we just said ah there's E3
uh what what if what if I take only four
first does it change very much yes that
one it doesn't work because I think that
you don't take back you play take Rook
take Queen takes A2 and I guess on Rook
I want to just go back to F7 or
something okay so it gives it gives like
additional options definitely okay but
E3 immediately I don't know how he's
planning on meeting this this is a piece
yeah you can take on A2 but after Rook
A1 it doesn't really matter where the
queen goes I snap take on
um well it couldn't be three maybe is
what he wants right oh no it doesn't it
doesn't make any difference yeah for
some reason I had this idiotic idea that
e takes D3 was actually attacking the
queen on C3 it does not but it does not
it does not so I just move away right I
mean it's a piece it's a piece yeah it's
gone you know it's pretty much gone
I don't get it again I'm trying to
Envision what he's envisioning what what
is he what is the trick how about a
bishop to D7 E3 Bishop D7 yeah what do
we take on D4 I think I take with a
check king of one oh you're supposed to
play King E2 and allow me rookie to
check king after on rookie two yeah yeah
s right ggs well yeah I mean it's a full
piece right it's a good piece I mean the
engine's just like plus 3.5
oh I mean I'm not gonna argue that point
that's right yeah it's very very
confusing because he was playing this
game so in like in such an interesting
fashion and so well until move 22 and
then like move 22 he was significantly
better on move 25 he is basically lost
against best play exactly very very odd
my goodness well we're gonna have to see
predictions one of these days because I
know I mean you know uh Alejandro's out
of the uh contention there on that one
he fought it he fought out a good
tournament for three rounds
no no no no no I mean told predictions
are coming
no you did great
three rounds really you did Alejandro I
mean we we we we
are coming back and be out yeah
the happy one here because West is in
the lead and also has a decent position
today might win it I don't understand
how can she possibly uh take over the
role of all of the social media with all
the chaos that's going on and predict
the winner of the tournament I mean
that's
that's to be fair I'm still tied with
VAR
last time you get the heels he'll say
that I don't
know
how
many
I mean my prediction is also really not
doing all that hot to be honest like and
VL is on minus one and is struggling
against Levon today well should it be I
shouldn't be the one to speak yeah
although I don't know how much he's
struggling let's go to that game
specifically because Maxine remember has
no time a minute and 14 seconds but he
found this really cool idea after H3 he
went Bishop G5 A4 Bishop F4 A5 and the
insistence to give up this Pawn to open
up avenues for this bishop but now it's
not just the bishop that's open it's
this Rook on C5 if for example you take
here uh you could play Rook G5
immediately the engines think Rook B5 is
slightly more accurate but whatever
let's put it a human move Rook G5 you
take on G2 is the idea and now this
bishop is defending C7 so you've
liberated your Rook not only towards the
fifth rank but also in the essence that
you don't have to be tied down to the
defense of that and the engines are
loving the way that mvl is playing
saying this was the way the engines are
now dropped down to zeros thinking that
this is the most accurate way of
defending this position so kudos to mvl
extremely fast player trust his
intuition he's still got a few more
moves to make he's got five more moves
to make before he's in the clear as far
as time control goes but guys he might
be getting there that is that is very
very nice really impressive I I I met in
the last four words actually on the 5v4
in that exact moment just
how often time how often we say this
Peter that when you're defending awkward
positions one of the best things you can
do is play for the initiative absolutely
yeah
and this idea of Rook G5 really I mean
it comes out of the blue uh like this
entire end game I understand it's a very
very difficult position and perhaps it
feels like I'm singling out one specific
instance in this tournament somewhat
unfairly but contrast this with how the
game between Yan and alireza went in
round whatever it was too
and eventually eventually he he did run
out of moves right and and lost whereas
mvl for the last 10 moves has been
trying to get rid of some material to
activate his pieces and looks like he's
finally succeeding uh let's just go down
this path for a moment because I take on
e4 Rook G5 I'm playing the move E4 I
think so I want to play for E6 I think
we take on E5 no no I mean G7 and D5
yeah dt7 I think we can yeah I suspect I
can maybe even take on YouTube here but
I think this is just to draw on this
side uh you weren't that afraid of E6
right I was like it's awkward but maybe
sometimes not that awkward but I think
this is just fine I'm a bit worried
about Rogue G5 but if all else fails
yeah this I just go be fine why am I
even worse I don't know before and I was
wondering if I can get my king I thought
my king was a limited time yeah okay so
let's not go Rook gp5 let's go Rook uh
huh down
G5 maybe okay I was gonna go after your
Pawn in any case
six G5
and we've got we've got a race this is a
race I'm probably happy with I don't
know I don't know it's it's very sharp
okay let's continue yeah G4 G4 okay
we're just gonna continue crazily like
this we go A7 H2 I've actually won the
Seattle C1 just wins here
um okay uh so can we just hang hang on
so E5 maybe it's clever to play a check
when your oppon's on G4
oh sorry uh in this Rook ending yeah
G5 just go down the line you probably
should have it right okay yeah take G5
here G4 A6 now give a check I think
right oh yeah this is this is much
better
King bitsu GH King B2 and Rook C1 I take
take G3 and G3 and then then the G Pawn
will Queen yeah so so here GH Rook C2
Rook G6 works here right
Rook G6 because you played King beat so
maybe you should you should have played
King eight but then Rook G2 right then
would be much stronger what what GH here
and now after Rook C2 I have rochito
because Rook is hanging amazing
wow and to show what I was doing in the
previous
this is just still still I'm warming up
the task here right hang on hang on whoa
whoa
um this is clever
I'm hoping this is very clever
um that in the pawns versus the Rooks
the pawns win the race
or Rook G3 you go Rook C1 correct
and I've run out of squares again this
is very intricate wow uh this is three
oh sorry no you yeah yeah
sorry take rookies three yes
uh I have to play King B1
I think not but I will continue giving
checks like I think I make a draw by
giving checks no way because H2O Rook H3
here I lost but I give a check here H2
Rook H3 was I think I lost yeah but I
have I have a check from G1
and then you can go over to the a file
yeah if you play King C2 I will pick up
your Rook very happily and I have okay
one exactly and if you play King before
I give a check again and you cannot go
to B3 because then I will play H2 Rook
H3 of just feature
magnificent I have no idea if this is
correct but this kind of feels correct
to me wow uh great stuff hey that
respects Peter dang those Rook endings
are nasty nasty uh piece of work there
in the meantime alireza has played it to
E3 and shot his black in the back in in
the tank but I think it's kind of late
the E3 back at the tank for a shack what
do you do and back back to this Lavon
game first if I finally started thinking
he's played something he's gone Rook 7
D4 trying to keep things under control
but you you
you imagine some kind of contemplate
connected with the pollen A5 might be
enough here I can't figure out
immediately how to get the bishop to the
squares I want to get to I mean
something like Rook E7 and I wanted to
start with it will be five for some
reason provoking A2 and then with the
King on 82 I was looking for some
counter play but maybe
somehow The Bishop's getting yeah I
wanted to get the bishop to be back on
C7 but I can't figure out exactly how to
get it there just the rookie seven yeah
actually I actually kind of like
provoking King A2 here because if you
take only four with the Rook yes I snap
it off I go Rook G5 yeah that's just
maybe a full screen because Maxim 20
seconds that's 25 seconds whoa whoa whoa
that's not two minutes and 20 seconds
that's 20 seconds and let's move 36 so
it has four moves to make on basically
the increment 15 14 13.
by the way I make a move I spoke about
the time continuum once your clock gets
under 10 seconds that is the fastest 10
seconds okay so he's just going to five
he says
no I don't like that movie that would
not have been my choice like what is
Dixie for like he wants what I don't
like F5 is did the engine does not like
F5 nobody likes that five I don't think
he liked that five but he needed to make
a move yeah well rookie seven or Rook B5
was the way to go I agree yeah if I just
did not look right and Lev obviously
snaps only four straight so thank you
very much that is a a very juicy Pawn no
yeah let us back to being significantly
better
wow that that wasn't great over to you
Alejandro no we should be watching this
oh sorry we should watch this we should
we should be watching this one with the
time with the clock yeah with the clocks
and the faces and everything here we are
irrelevant here 52 seconds for real and
he's gone fp4 King H6 a kind of a
waiting move trying to activate it with
via the G5 Square whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa uh okay no E5 sorry Bishop E5 Rook
H4 whatever I think we're setting it
short yes exactly I think I have to be
looking for more
um okay Peter are we looking at ef ef is
five Rook F1 and then Rook F1 perhaps
that would be definitely one version of
what I want to achieve here even maybe
the immediate Rook F1 is not horrible
um the immediate Rook F1 oh
I didn't cross my mind that looks hey
black steel can go I guess King G5 I
don't think we are actually achieving
all that much by starting with that move
it's still not like I if I if I had this
with white I would not be sure I'm
winning but it's definitely an
improvement over what we had like a
three five moves of garlic no question
about it yeah
no question I would still be I would
still be on unsure if it's already
entirely enough or not and they and uh
Lev is doing the right thing in in
pausing because the uh the landscape
changed the structure is very new I I
loved your move Rook F1
let me take that
Brook takes and let me just improve my
king this is something something along
the lines of what I wanted yeah just
because I've got this Rook G4 check yeah
we've pinned everything yeah we've sort
of pinned everything we want the King on
G3 perhaps if we can get this yes yes
and now we can start improving on the
queen side yeah that that I mean then
everybody's working and in Harmony and
yes a lot of happiness in the white
absolutely I I agree with it with all of
that
uh but the moves are going uh three most
time controllers yeah three most of time
control levels as I said Lev is doing
absolutely the right thing in not hiring
like fe4 was forced pretty much so he
played it instantly but now after King
H6 he did give himself like a minute and
a half perhaps to you know reacquaint
himself with uh with what's going on
because it's a it's a new position
efrika 5-2 to go and mvl is now up to a
minute and 18 so he's in a safer
position on the clock but I mean clearly
he was doing better on the board a bit a
bit earlier by the way love did not
include the move broken you can probably
still do it he likes the Rooks on the D
file I suppose yeah I mean he can oh
yeah he can he can do it now I don't
think very many things have changed
exactly the reason I liked it initially
is because it forced King G5 and here I
feel like I am giving you parmi I'm
giving my opponent options yeah so I've
always liked to reduce my opponents that
is that is fair but I don't know if Rook
CF7 actually necessarily changes very
much and whereas G5 yeah G5 is just ugly
I don't think we
Rook D6 sorry yeah okay there is a
there's a nasty excuse me yeah no I
think G5 like your yeah it's it's your
last resort I think there's black here
you would much rather make any other
movie right a group of seven or King G5
here I think is vastly preferable to
having to play G5 26 seconds 26 seconds
back yeah so we're yeah we're going to
watch this to to its con I mean not the
conclusion but to move 40 I think it's
it's very natural for us to be watching
this until they they get to
to the final four of the first time
control here it goes seven seconds
he decided that Rook C7 to F7 was
Superior to King G5 I'm sort of
interested in the idea of playing B3
before right now just because the pin
kind of stops black from being able to
attack that pawn before straight away
and I think I might be threatening 96
next move that's my my biggest reasoning
there is that like let's say we played
before yeah that goes I don't know King
G5 okay and my idea here is to claim
that I can play 96 you will have to take
yeah I will take on F5 I will take on D6
and I will pick up the A6 Pawn I will
lose my king side but I think I'm
probably faster here I think so too I
think I'm faster and this is why I'm
somewhat interested in in B3 before but
there are more restrained options
available King C2 the move that we
mentioned earlier is definitely a
playable move
um
and uh by the way LaRosa has won his
game he just won he's straight up like
my meds decided I'm down a piece
oh did the xc4 is also such a solid
final move in this game just saying
there will not even be any checks along
the e-file and the Knight on D4 is still
completely indefensible oh dear so yeah
alireza wins a very a very kind of a
dramatic game where he was in trouble he
wasn't genuine trouble huge turnaround
and then five moves later his opponent
just resigned because back to the Lavon
game again just for a moment because
it's sort of like boy that that that
concept I want to say a B4 Knight D6 is
super attractive I've got to say I think
it's that could be winning it's the way
to at least maybe create a winning
thread I mean black has ways of dealing
with it like you can play Rook whichever
one you like more to F6
and that stops our 96 Shenanigans but
now we can look in C2 and I think the
inclusion of Rook to F6 and King C2 has
to be in our favor probably the
inclusion of B4 exactly wow I think
we've connected our pawns on on the
queen side we've made some progress and
black really is still kind of shuffling
in place exactly but
I don't know I mean I think it's also a
good move as a move 40. because I think
you are asking a very very concrete
question and I think in this position
this is the only move that asks a
concrete question everything else will
allow black to play something King C2
yeah can choose from a number of things
because 96 is not a threat it can go
King G5 you can go Rook F6 you can maybe
even move the bishop away and try to get
to the F2 Square
um by by trading groups I see so plenty
of options I think before is the move
that really is the most challenging yeah
is the most a question the most concrete
the most concrete thing you can ask your
opponent in this position it certainly
feels that way and again would that be
move 40 Peter it will be yeah it will be
a long move to go uh uh uh mvl is down
to 35 seconds but 35 seconds in most
cases he will have a reasonably natural
move to choose from
see just the bird's eye view of the
players uh once again yeah I think we
were talking about Lavon having like 40
minutes or there's about 39 yeah yeah
and
this is a kind of an interesting one
right because I think maybe the most
unpleasant thing for for mvl here from a
purely uh kind of a psychological point
of view would be to actually think here
for like 15 minutes
but nobody has the patience for it
also also the position really isn't
complicated enough for you to
legitimately think for 15 minutes I
think you come to some kind of a
conclusion within I don't know the first
five but for mvl who is on 35 seconds
cannot get up exactly he's yeah he's
just yeah he's just there you know and
and you just think and think and think
and he is just there kind of stewing
while levonis has doing uh we are very
fortunate we have uh our winner
absolutely uh and since everyone really
isn't making you move perhaps we should
actually switch to uh to a very very
interesting interview because I want to
know what alaras are thought of of his
position in at various points in the
game it was a was a very uh dramatic
game let's ask him Alejandro over to you
here with an early winner of this round
alireza tell us a little bit about this
game you seem like a roller coaster take
us from the opening over here yeah I
think um I messed up the move order
this line I should not go Knight C2
definitely you mean in this position
after Queen takes D5 yeah yeah because
here Greenwich but this is still okay of
course it's equal and yeah I played
normal but yeah here it's very
complicated I mean it's not clear how
black has to develop also
I think it's easier for me to play a bit
but he played very well actually a five
P5 Bishop D4
yeah here I'm better for sure yes but I
should have played like short Castle or
something now tell us a little bit about
this decision you put the Rook on D1
right and then you decided nah let's put
the Rook on B1 yeah because here is
different right I mean here my phone is
on B5 already so
just to have some tricks at some point
also for instance with Knight C5 Knight
takes E4 works oh Charizard real quick
95 here and it takes E4 yeah yeah it
works right Bishop yeah this is why we
need Rook on B1 yeah yes Bishop takes B2
Knight takes C5 yes 965 yeah it does
work okay yeah I wanted some tricks like
this but he played C5 he kept his Bishop
on D4 and here it completely blundered
the idea of Bishop still here I spent a
lot of time
um thinking better to include H4 or not
but it's okay at night yeah it's a
blunder I think but but maybe I'm still
okay right so
um the computers were so happy about
your position let's put it that way they
were not happy right there's a minus two
minus two yeah Queen takes D5 how what
did you think was gonna happen after
Rook F1 yeah I think here he has to play
very concretely I mean C4 I couldn't
after C4 make my position work but
C4 in this position just clamping down
on your opponents
Rook F4 let's say F5 whoa whoa just yeah
because now I don't have D3 right right
you definitely don't have E3
and uh
what what was the line I was thinking
yeah not instead of Rook F4 maybe after
C4
uh yeah Rook C1 maybe just attacking
this Pawn right because he cannot uh now
Knight E5 is very important 95 and if I
take on e4 yeah Bishop before Queen B5
Queen B5 it was Knight D3 I take this
queen yes nothing show that real quick
93 Queen D3 right and it works yes this
works okay Queen D3 Bishop D3 is an
equal but okay it's fine right now I
think what the engines were saying was
actually the move uh B6 just keeping on
to the position
when you when you play the move Knight
f8
what did you analyze yeah I immediately
thought that if Queen C3 did you expect
this one no I didn't I immediately
thought if I queen C3 F6 I have Rook F6
then I'm better because uh because he
has he's not developed and the pawn on
e4 is very weak so it was very weird
move for him right and queen C3 and he
it collapsed so then you look at four
and here he has to of course go for some
end game I think
uh some like Queen D4 and
and here we have some options Queen did
Queen takes on D4
Knight takes yeah here as it's at
minimum I could take angle Rook E4 and
I'm better thanks tags are working for
yes it does look a little more pleasant
for a white test on D4 and strong
Bishops okay yeah maybe bishop F5 but I
could get get a good position anyway I
think right and after F5 were you
surprised by this move as well yeah I
think he already had to bail out but he
was in shock that he is not winning
already
so he was he wanted to still play for
win and but yeah it didn't and after D3
and still he has to go Queen D4 or queen
takes A2 I saw it also maybe rookie 1.5
and immediately go Queen D4 back on the
next one right uh what what do you think
went through his mind when he played the
movie knight D4 I think he blundered the
E3 probably right I mean he thought that
E3 can never be played somehow with the
Rook on E8 but uh yeah now if after
Bishop takes F2 he he saw that my
position is still playable he was a bit
maybe annoyed I think that he didn't
want immediately right I think so yeah
well he still gotta win One games and in
this one you came back how do you feel
up today's game satisfied or do you feel
that you shouldn't have plundered yeah I
think it was a very shaky game
um obviously I had two rest days so I
finished off Tuesday or out of the
composition kind of so and I'm happy at
least I'm back getting back to the game
so I'm it's a decent
I cannot be too happy so
um yeah I take it anyway the business of
course we take those other what'd you do
on the rest days
yeah we went with Eric Rosen to tennis
and
um yeah and we watched the game
yesterday in 10 also tennis at midnight
it was very interesting so did you say
until the end yeah I stayed up it did
land it was in I couldn't sleep because
I had to watch it I might explain Bishop
takes up
yeah that's great well Arisa thanks for
joining us here and good luck thank you
thank you alireza congratulations on
your Victory today let's just take a
quick uh we look at our results people
we only have one but there it is uh yeah
it's an important result in the context
of the grandchild story in particular
because there isn't with that picture I
think climbs to plus one right yeah it's
now sort of in a virtual tie for first
uh with the rest of the guys who are on
plus one and he is uh uh leading the
tour along with mvl he's a point behind
MBL coming underground yeah uh so after
his brilliant and considering the fact
that MBL is you know very much fighting
for survival today uh and we could maybe
just quickly bring up what's happening
in mvl's game because sure he did allow
96 which was a very interesting decision
and this is now the end game that we
have there uh and we were fearful we we
were looking at some of these Rook
endings where you know if we ever get
into a race it's not much of a race I'm
getting the pawn and they also now
interestingly he spent a tempo here on
Rooker 504 it doesn't really change very
much because I'm pretty sure we're never
taking on A6 here I'm pretty sure we're
always playing rugby six absolutely as
far as I understand it and my question
is like are we probably the plan really
is G5 G4 maybe because otherwise I don't
really see what we've gained by by
playing Rook F4 but uh anyway in terms
of the GC standings is my my kind of
overall point alireza is now on plus one
right whereas mvl is on minus one right
and potentially maybe even losing today
like if he makes a draw it will not be
an easy draw he might he might still
make it it's not a an automatically
losing position the one he has right now
but he has to work for it yes and if
those results actually uh do happen and
VL drops back to -2 and the reson plus
one with three to go alireza I think
becomes a very very serious front runner
for for the overall GCT prize don't
forget about Wesley so and we're gonna
of course on the other side of this
break don't go anywhere
foreign
[Music]
Louis the Ascension Charity Classic
presented by Emerson is back this
September don't miss the excitement when
the PGA toured Champions best compete
again all for charity September 9th
through the 11th at Norwood Hills
Country Club Pro-Am spots Hospitality
packages VIP tickets and more available
now at Ascension charityclassic.com
[Music]
if you have kids you already know St
Louis has a ton of fun stuff for
families to do like the magic house or
the science center and if you really
want to be a stellar parent come see all
the new stuff there is to discover at St
Louis Union Station with a new Mirror
Maze light shows and the 20-story high
St Louis wheel it's enough to make any
parent feel like a star
St Lou is always exploring
[Music]
we're the Corey family Welcome to our
show
[Music]
you guys
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Cup
2022 and one game has already finished
and as opposed to many rounds prior to
today that game was a decisive game the
first game of the round was a very very
quick victory for alirez roller coaster
ride as alirez was probably losing
before he got much worse at the very
least yeah and uh during our break Peter
you and I have been looking at the game
of Lavon aronian and I've got lots of
questions for you the move Rook B8 that
really was
a strange one it was unexpected yeah and
uh I I feel like perhaps I was very much
spoiled by uh having uh as we go into
the studio we've passed the uh yeah the
the anti-chamber where we're Alejandro
does his magic with his with his smart
smart uh Sport and uh I noticed that
before B5 appeared to be completely
winning on his board right but I don't
know if like if you don't know that how
obvious is that supposed to be to you
because the move Rook B4 check before
checkbook was also also I wanted to say
a takes B5
look at this King on H5 anytime I play
G4 is a check maybe maybe this is but
that don't know G4 honestly I don't know
how happy I am with this right G4
immediately right now I think we have to
do it now
and if before this probably is a draw
now because I think the king escapes
right Rook B6 king of five
so we were supposed to play King B3
instead but why is this a drive again
maybe you saw the Droid yeah we go King
B3 here and then HG and we cannot take
on G4 because Rook B4 okay four will
create a bridge yeah exactly
this is very tricky wow but uh but also
if b55 well I I saw B5 and I saw Rook B4
check and I said well how clear is that
Peter yeah we're still not entirely
shirking c2a takes B5 and then perhaps
King C3 here and suddenly once again
you're kind of one tempo away from
establishing the setup probably why
don't we go A6
and uh okay one king before the king
gets to before and if the king gets to
before you kind of assume this is right
otherwise once again the set of the
black ones is Rook on A4 with the King
cutoff on the third sure and then
normally you don't have any weigh-in
but the bigger question for me was if
we're not doing any of that why are we
not just playing I don't know King C2
King B3 and I think the answer to that
is that livon feels that the biggest
source of counter play Black has in this
position is G4 followed by perhaps even
G3 and then Rook F2 right and the movie
the movie one made is very clearly aimed
at stopping that and that precisely
because G5 G4 currently just loses on
the spot The Rook hhgregate check and
look to hg4 and we've preserved
everything while winning a very
important Pawn on the other side of the
board like just kind of resigns here
exactly uh so we've stopped this is this
source of counter play but we are of
course allowing black to give a couple
of checks and to take on G2 I assume I'm
going to go to the beach but currently I
don't see how we actually prevent this
from questing as at least the Rook after
before B5
um because ABA 6 our Rook is actually
not getting to the a file in time blue
G3 check King before and we've run out
of checks and then A7 will cost us
currently there will definitely be
positions where black would be okay with
requesting them a rook but currently
currently even that maybe is not on tap
because yeah yeah you don't even get to
play G4 in the position where I do win a
rook uh G4 as it always runs into rookie
okay yeah uh so perhaps perhaps one has
calculated all of these things correctly
and black then does not really have very
much in a way of you know active things
to do or proactive things to do in the
current position if you if you cannot
really play G5 G4 and you also cannot
seemingly
and then you obviously have to give a
check from it too because otherwise it's
very unclear what you're doing with your
life exactly and he's done that he has
done that and after King B3 once again
it feels like you have to take on G2
B5 so let's look at this position what
would be the way to we have Rook G2 on
the board yeah and uh Lev obviously will
play B5 because otherwise yeah you can't
spend a Tempo on Rook B6 here you it was
on B6 this is this is not why you've
gone for this entire life exactly
and B5 on the board yeah uh some very
very very high Fallout
G1 technique Alejandro oh you guys said
it yeah everywhere like there's nothing
for me to add you guys are right this is
just lost this is what we've achieved in
life you know we've reduced Alejandro
the silence it's taken us five solid
rounds
to actually get something right from
start to finish right well done okay but
b510 it's the end yeah Rook giban you
would like to play Rook G1 but this year
is Rook h a check and then B takes A6
and it's once again just basically a
queen oh my goodness ba and The Rook
doesn't get to the seventh in time so we
got G4 but that's just not the time I
mean yeah ba A7 it's just I guess you
get mated yeah like you can you can get
a queen as well but you will get mated
like in three months now G4 just played
G4 yeah b-a-g-h A7 H2 A8 H H I also that
I guess but and actually an immediate
resignation thereby by MBL yeah
he's seen enough
wow that looks like a great technical
achievement especially I want to loud
the move Rook E4 in Rook D7 not
capturing the E5 pawn it was a very very
nicely played game I think both in terms
of you know the moves he made but also
something that Alejandro was
highlighting just as we even as we were
watching the game unfold was he he very
early on I think he realized his
position is better but not necessarily
winning but his winning chances will
greatly increase if he will just never
give any respite to MBL on the clock and
he continued pressuring him by playing
as quickly as possible without sort of
relinquishing control and in the end of
mvl uh cracked and started making
mistakes even though like by move 35
once unveil 25 before I thought he might
be a favorite to save the game at that
point but how do you if he has like 10
minutes at that point I think he never
loses but on 30 seconds he eventually
started making mistakes including that
F5 move but when you think about the
game holistically from the very start
with Rook on H1 to F1 an important
approach a different approach putting
questions that whole Bishop B7 and then
this great end game technique I mean it
really looks like a fantastic fantastic
world-class game two results two results
both of them white wins actually white
is doing incredibly well in this
tournament there's been uh I mean apart
from the Carlson Neiman game which is
you know the entire tournament basically
at this point but but like if we if we
somehow forget this ever happened right
if we make it one if we have it with
black yeah a concerted concerted mental
effort and we forget that ever happened
and there you go life is doing really
really well yesterday uh two games one
uh by white two games remaining the game
between Hans Neiman and Wesley Wesley
is making progress I'm gonna say time
progress oh yeah the night is on G1
they're like probably the worst Square
on the board probably yeah actually the
only worst score than G1 was F3
oh really yeah F3 was horrible it's
horrible so it's horrible it might not
be the best Square for now on G1 but I
think it's an improvement actually I
went with it through the with the
engines for a while and they did not
like
having the Knight on F3 so much that
they were willing to give up the pot on
H4 in many variations right and in this
particular version it does say that
because of the last move that Hans just
played King E2 that Wesley is very close
to Victory the engines like the move
Knight E2 again there's a pin here so
I'm not losing my power on H4 in this
particular case and you know on a good
day I play Knight C3 on new blunder this
Knight takes D5 tactic right but
uh after King E2 I think I just want to
play Bishop H2
it's a very clever move because this
Knight I want to force it back to its
worse and then we go before and we
actually win that end game and then we
go here and we've analyzed similar end
Gates and this one is a particularly bad
version of it Knight D2 I think the
pawning game is not one but I wouldn't
actually this might also be lost it
might also be lost yeah I think it's
just straight up lost so you have to go
with the Knights somewhere very awkward
either E1 or G1 but by that point I get
my king to D5 there's no question that
that's a lost any game so Bishop H2 is a
very clever move in this position I
think that you would have to play Knight
H3 which is just as bad of a square as
F3 is because it's quite controlled uh
the engines want to play can move King
D6 just bring the king closer and not
allow the move Queen takes E4 which four
is hanging as well yeah and now H4 is
hanging so you're gonna again have to
defend this very very awkwardly now
after King A2 only Bishop H2 is directly
winning why is this one not winning
Apparently after taking taking a knight
H3 and only Knight H3 you have F3 on the
next move and things are not so clear so
this is an important distinction that if
the Knight can still go to H3 you don't
want to transfer into the end game that
being said it's still an advantage black
you could still try to win this end game
but the precise move is Bishop H2
yeah Bishop H2 is a very nice very nice
[ __ ] I I must say it's a move that I
find myself attracted to because I like
the idea of boarding the night back on
F3 so I can go Bishop it's it's findable
it's findable and it I think the biggest
question there is just to kind of
realize it exists and then instantly you
feel that yes this has to be the correct
solution right yeah warm up to it right
away now if uh that by the way that
would be amazing we would have three
decisive games uh let me just double
check we kind of lost it a little while
ago because I thought that Fabi sorry
yeah was closer to a drawing I think
it's still true I think it's still true
and currently I mean the big kind of if
if we call this Intrigue and okay Rook
A4 has been played not what I expected
uh but the Tactics still exists we can
play Bishop B6 here and then oh yeah we
don't even need to do that yeah which B6
Rook F4 I guess is the idea right okay
oh sorry yeah five I think is an
immediate draw because I don't I take on
G2 next month right uh and if you play
Rook F4 my point is uh I can play among
other things H3 GH Rook D3 and just take
on A3 or I can play Bishop takes H3 and
defend the road condition Bishop against
stroke I don't know which one Fabi
prefers but all of this is yeah we have
a victory interviews which is kind of
more important than any of this very
good over to you Alejandro
with Levon aronian here after a great
win against Maxine vasher La Graf you
went into the lions then you came with
preparation you took the night Earth and
you found this move Rook hf1 tell us a
little bit about the inspiration of this
I didn't really find it uh when I was
struggling with uh some health issues in
India it was that they were preparing
Fabi
for night of I think it was against
masudu and Robert has came up with this
idea to play Rook F1 here Grandmaster
Robert has the coach of the US Olympics
team in India and then we analyzed it a
bit
and we gave Fabia green light and well
it didn't happen on his board but I
think we both were looking for an
opportunity to play this very
interesting idea and tell us a little
bit what is the point of putting the
Rook on F1 rather than the normal Rook
he1
yeah quite often you get this I mean
when black for example makes a long
Castle here
quite often you have to play like C4
let's say Knight F4 Bishop B6 uh Bishop
of six Bishop of six Bishop B4
96 985 Knight C5 and if the Rook only
one if the Rook is standing on E1 then
we don't have those options to play B4
here because B4 ft key at some point but
here The Rook is hitting the bishop and
then Queen to D5 and also just in case
Rook on F1 I mean we're kind of stopping
some uh
ideas because we want to play a four
adult times right so it's I won't say
it's uh granting white any advantage but
it's a new try and I thought why not the
engines were saying that Knight H7 was
the best move in this position and after
a very long think Maxine found it were
you surprised that he played what seems
like a bit of an inhuman move
no I'm not surprised because he's a very
strong player but I think at one moment
he of course found this best idea at one
moment he just got careless on move
number 19. of course Rook H7 is to move
we were wondering what is the difference
uh with Rook H7 he manages to put the
King on f8
faster and there's never like danger for
him starting from the you know Queen H6
check right yes he always gets it
yeah because the Rook is just defending
yeah yeah so it's just safer for his
King and also Rook can be surprisingly
effective at protecting the F7 Pawn in
different lines so this was the way to
equalize but you knew about Rook G I
tell us a little bit about where your
knowledge ended
I knew that Rook G8 is not the right
move and here I just thought and I
thought well Knight D5 looks quite
logical right 95 in this position play
continued King f8 Bishop B4 King G7 and
after Queen takes D6 did you feel you
were in control yeah this looks like a
very nice position but uh I think later
on I started playing
sub-optimal moves I think I gave him
some chances maybe I should have just
grabbed the
actually we loved your move rookie four
objectively according to my engine it
evaluated both as about the same amount
of advantage and we thought that from a
practical perspective considering his
time situation rookie 4 was just a
better move
that's that's what I thought as well but
then somehow he got this contemplate I
mean his Maximus saw resource so with
this H4 Bishop G5 I think already here I
I was feeling that my advantage is
slowly disappearing yes yeah and then I
thought okay A4 well with A4 of course I
allow Rook take C4 which I thought is
very close to the draw this one Rook
takes immediately pontex Rook text A5
and Rook B4 check
this is hanging this is hanging yeah I
was thinking that this is this is
already a bit uh out of my control I was
thinking that maybe I have some Rook B7
here but this is rugby seven way too
doubling yeah because Rook A2 check here
is also kind of unpleasant night King V3
or K5
ah then you just try The Rook yeah so I
have to play some King C3 and
I don't know if I have any winning
chances here after some E4 or something
like that right it gets it gets messy he
didn't find that if he actually went for
this variation with A5 E4 Rook 7 D4 this
we love this move thought it was very
clever during the time control yeah it
was the only chance to win the game I
felt because otherwise it just says too
much counter play and that's the thing
he kind of from distance he thought he
has his Rook V7 on Rook V5 but then
rookie 4 is there and he cannot
recapture the pawn because rugby three
King situ Rook before King C3 let me put
that on the board rugby sound or Rook B5
it doesn't matter doesn't matter take
check Rook here and you're attacking
both the rook and the bishop and I'm
assuming on Rook before you have King C3
right yes you attack the rooken again
the bishop on F4 so it doesn't have time
to do that and he blitzed out F5 with
seconds
rookie seven is is should be a draw yeah
rookie seven is what we uh the engines
were suggesting as well as we do have a
finally a result in this game we had
been expecting it for upwards of three
hours by this point nepo Astron against
Bobby so going back into this analysis
rookie 7 did seem to be good but you got
to this position out of time control did
you feel that you were already winning
in this end game yeah yeah I felt King
H5 was a losing move I felt that his
only chance was Bishop G5 but then I
felt I have this clever Rook takes F5
Rook F5 Knight D6
and you know
um my knife is very useful because I
have this Knight F7 check when he takes
the pawn r94 when it goes through F2
yeah level one it seems that you put a
lot of pressure on your opponent on the
board but I've noticed on your style
that you've also playing very quickly it
almost reminding me of how nepo wins a
lot of his games is this on purpose yeah
I'm trying to learn from my
colleagues and uh also well I haven't
won a classical game for so long that I
think I'm losing patience
well this one was definitely a beautiful
one with the ideas in the in the opening
in the middle game and in the end game
winning all around thank you everyone
for joining us and good luck
uh Lavon quick question any help you
with choosing the shirt
absolutely absolutely you like it I love
it I love it if you can get an extra
large from me you know because of my
swollen pectorals that would be great
absolutely
thank you Lavon this is a nice draw by
the way I love that Bishop F3 45 that
really put a a nice Finishing Touch yeah
I'm pretty sure it's not the only thing
that draws there but Bishop 3 is quite
clever for sure business repetition yeah
this Final Touch we just left it when
Lavon came into studio with this move
Bishop F3 basically said go ahead take
my Bishop I'll take yours and sure
you're going to be a pawn up but this is
going to be so easy for me to draw it's
trivial yeah so yeah in the end very
nicely defended game by 5B uh he uh came
up with this idea of it's It's a
somewhat I think uncharacteristic idea
for fiber specifically because I think
Fabi is a very active player in general
and as I Alejandra was seeing from the
from the very beginning you know he he
generally doesn't I think play lines
like these
too often I think compared to some other
top players because you're basically
abandoning all pretense of ever having
any winning chances right by move 15 you
know what your what your faith in life
will be in this game you will have to
play precisely and then you will make a
draw but he did make it I think
reasonably comfortably I don't think he
was ever particularly stretched so here
you are you're in a bishops of opposite
color you're a pawn down but once you
get into the position sort of say well
there's your winning chances are small I
have none uh and I'm probably a big big
favor to try to think so I think
demonstrated exactly why that is yeah in
this game just playing very very solidly
making no mistakes finding the small
tactics when small tactics needed to be
to be calculated did did it cross your
mind uh the Anatoly karpov Omen when you
put the bishop on C7 and you control the
C5 a little bit a little bit but yeah
eventually the Rooks still have to come
open exactly
doesn't really change all that much and
we have uh more interviews so let's go
to Alejandra
here with Fabiana who never disappoints
in his opening preparation probably tell
us a little bit about this one it's a
little bit of the trodden path but you
seem to make it work very easily I mean
I can't really call it deep preparation
this was played in a Blitz game
between Jan and Richie and like in Paris
up to up to Bishop takes E6 BC Rook B6 I
I think he didn't play H6
but like up to 21 this was played in The
Blitz game oh the entire thing we must
have missed that we don't have Blitz
Games on our database we apologize for
that it was it was in the grand chess
tour and we do see a lot of games
you're forgiven for that thank you so
why do you think he went for this
variation it does seem that it doesn't
offer that many chances for well the
opening was just a surprise for him I
mean I've never played this this four
nights with Bishop before I mean usually
if I play four nights I try to get a
question called and I think that's what
he was aiming for some sort of
complicated question call
fight and I surprised him and you know
white doesn't have so many Alternatives
um it's a relatively foreseen line there
are some Alternatives but you have to to
know what they are and and some details
about them so he
okay I think Bishop takes G6 is just a
better chance than Bishop C6 we go back
to uh here Bishop takes on G6 it's it's
also super Josh Rook B6 so I mean but
white does remain up a pawn right black
doesn't get the pawn back immediately
Knight D4 C3 Knight C2 Rook C1 right
there's a game actually of adiban in
this position yeah Knight takes eight I
I guess
um
I guess he made a drawn I I must have
seen this game but I no I was actually
one he lost his game okay yeah so the
line goes relaxed sorry black lost that
game was white okay yeah rupee seven I
mean it remains tricky black plays F6
this should be three Knight C4 the
bishop should go to D4 is the best
square and then it's very important to
play G5 to stop H4 we're considering
that because in the long term G7 might
be a weakness black needs a structure
with the with the g-pawn and it's not
like black gets the pawn back you know
why it plays this position and black
basically has some sort of Fortress I
mean it doesn't look like a fortress but
white can't really make progress in the
long run and uh so you're confident
making a draw from this position I
thought so I mean I knew more or less
that a pair of Works will get traded why
people play Rook C2 at some point to
stop the invasion of Rook A2 bring the
king to the center and black will also
bring the king to the center and and
we'll read reach some sort of impasse
like for example Rook C7 Rook fc8 take
take King G1
on a rook A8 Rook C2 king of seven
King F2 King E6 can you flag this
position something like this right yeah
and uh of course it's not fun but if you
know that it's it should be a draw then
then you kind of figure it out
um
so yeah this is a slightly better chance
than the Obstacle of Bishops although I
felt like I got under pressure with some
inaccurate play in the game you it felt
that you had to solve a few problems but
that you had it all under control was
there a particular moment when you felt
under danger no just I I played this um
which one was it when I played G5 I
don't think this is necessary I mean G5
in this position yeah maybe something
like Bishop T6 is more just keeping the
position yeah because then then it
becomes concrete after Bishop d8 this
what happened in the game right like
yeah so here I could have played
um
King G6 Rook D3 and I could have played
Bishop to E6 yes and then Rook D6
King F5
um
uh yeah I can get five Bishop G5 I think
is the best chance King G5 because okay
I don't know Rook A3 is a bit dangerous
I mean black is really tied up so King
G5 so you don't want to go into this you
want to take here uh-huh and then make
this cake and and this type of ending is
a draw
but it's not a fun one no and I was like
I spent like 20 minutes thinking about
this position trying to remember what I
what I knew about this ending
um because white basically plays like
Rook E1
King back Rook F1 G3 King H3 F4 and then
and this is the plan oh let me put this
King somewhere
yeah let's say King H3 wait Rook F1
weight G3
yeah and now F4 King goes back
rookie one I mean this stuff is very
dangerous because the Rook invades uh
I I couldn't even remember exactly how
Black Drawers I think like there's
there's only one one
um method in which black draws its
position so it's it's not didn't seem
easy and I decided not to go for this
so instead you went for the move H4
check kept the Bishops on the board a
couple tricks here but nothing really
worked for him yeah I didn't see
anything in particular but it wasn't
super fun to play this after Bishop B7
there was a I think Rook D4 was
important
me go back to 39 39 Bishops if I play G4
then Bishop B4 I think I might lose this
because it just traps the Rope on the
wrong side not only that but I made it
after details
like if I could play G3 King G1 and get
my Rook somewhere active like to d8 D4
or something then
um probably it's all all good right but
here I've just made it I got like a
brickade yeah I have to play rookie and
okay well not just ugly but he just
starts pushing his a pawn and I lose
oh that's pretty ugly because my king is
not just trapped momentarily but it's
trapped forever yeah so Rook D4 was
important and after that I I didn't feel
in huge danger but
yeah it wasn't super fun but uh I never
saw a moment when I was like
in real Danger
yeah it seems that you kept the draw
always well in hand uh tell us a little
bit about what you did and then in your
free day that's a good question
um besides some tennis which
people know
know about already because
it was posted a photo was posted on
Twitter and it got like
um a million yeah I'm still getting
getting commentary on that one picture
yeah
sorry I couldn't oh he said that he's
still getting commentary on that picture
oh yeah yeah I'm I mean I'm sure all the
all the likes were because I was in it
I mean I'm not gonna lie the top two
comments on Reddit of that picture are
thank you for bringing svidler I'm gonna
avoid using one word that was added
there and Fabi is a cutie so I think I
think the conversation is about you too
that's very flattering um yeah and thank
you for bringing this video is basically
like it take your grandma to work day
kind of
I mean Reddit is is the the place to um
to read up on trust news isn't
absolutely uh but yeah that was one
thing and then
um I have to I have to say that I didn't
really think I couldn't think about
Chess yesterday at all
um and today I also couldn't think about
Chess whatsoever and I more or less
didn't prepare
um because my mind was elsewhere uh
uh without like going into details but
it wasn't so easy to to focus on chess
all right do you want to leave it there
yeah okay sounds good well Fabi a solid
draw here against Nepal you must be
satisfied considering that apparently
you can't think about Chess uh yeah no
the result is good
um other results were not so good for me
but my result was okay I guess Wesley
will also win
uh we think that it seems like yeah well
we got to this position give us your
opinion on it
doesn't look great I mean
what does what I do here uh Knight C2 or
or there's D5 like d526 you'll start
shedding materials yeah that's that's a
square right and then because let's just
point to the audience that if you play
here on E5 I think you have Knight G4
yeah it's still not very nice but yeah
it's a better version of five yeah but
it's pointless because D5 King D6 just
wins that pawn right well not G2 still
exists but it starts looking very very
but after King E5 this is just terrible
yeah this Knight is completely dominated
yes okay this should be lost so I guess
Knight C2 and of King default King E3
and he holds it together and he has an
ib4 check and black can play A5 here
completely paralyzing white oh this just
looks like a zoo yeah I don't know if
there's B4 but uh you also are not
forced to play King D5 if you can maybe
play some kind of a waiting move perhaps
like a six or five might be decent here
and five can can white take the
opportunity to play F3
Maybe
sorry and now King D5 King E3 I'll take
on F3 Knight before
uh King King G6 you might see two I like
I'm oh you're trying to survive this I'm
not happy but I'm just trying to hold on
like this can you yeah okay I missed I
missed that you can go back yeah I miss
thinking well yeah there's still the H
Pawn like they should be six king of
three yeah maybe this is actually still
winning for black here yeah it probably
is because King G3 Bishop six white is
again dominated it definitely doesn't
seem like a great chances here yeah yeah
this is probably probably resigns at
this point I don't like I don't even see
a move there so I don't know Knight C2
yeah F5
um D5 check by the way play
yeah Wesley is
uh is really at home in these types of
uh technicals can he play Knight G4 F5
Knight F6 like just out of pure
desperation
and Knight of Fate I mean Bishop D4
though no uh and 97 Bishop G7 yeah and
then we've collected stuff yeah I don't
really believe in my G8
yeah probably not but you know like
Bishop Bishop D4 and Knight G8 oh okay
Bishop G7 I mean I I guess that and
something King E3 I I don't know it's
it's actually designed it's still a game
yeah
I think you are resigning though King
takes D5
King E6
check okay
oh you have H5
uh sorry yeah there is yeah we have H5
so I actually gained weight 10 years yes
here King D4 it's not also King D4 king
of 695 is escaping oh yeah so 75.
yeah I mean this this looks close trying
to get closer to he's already played 9g2
so we are
he played my G2 yeah my G4 against
Bishop D4 simply we don't even play a
fight you know Bishop D4 Knight F4 now
no there in this position I played
Knight G4 no he played 9g2 oh okay sorry
I'm I'm game yeah and here we go King E5
I guess right and uh okay so D6 must be
his idea right but unfortunately even if
you break up those I I have G5 there and
H5 is not a queen yeah yeah but but this
is not clear clear cut anymore no take
take I mean the pawns are getting less
Knight H3 yeah G4 knight uh
but I think B3 is just falling like I go
King E5 King the [ __ ] C3 I'm just
gonna abandon everything on the other
side yeah King E5 on the board by the
way yeah this looks pretty bad uh
allowing D6 for what it's worth okay so
let's try f 3 if we can
not D6 Fabi F3 I think we probably like
Bishop B8 probably just kind of ends the
game right Bishop B8 I was thinking
Bishop C5 actually
my point is I want to give I want to
take away neither four altogether and
then like took SpongeBob but there
should be at 93 doesn't it seem like the
end of the world no why
F okay but like you have no moves
King G4 next like I will I will just
continue denying you moves and
eventually I think this will have to
collapse now especially with the power
on H4 right yeah I think I think this
has to be lost yeah this looks terrible
yeah
that might be a big victory for Wesley
he's currently on plus one and he's
taking down one of the other players
with plus one yeah for him this is huge
because he's also
in the running in the grandchild tour
right right uh if he does well if he
wins a tournament he probably clinches
clinch is the first place in the
branches tour and uh and now he's going
to be in the clear lead
um I guess okay also alireza had a very
big day because he's
also doing well yes and uh and yet for
that the maxim lost
yeah uh yeah Maxine losing and going on
my S2 is is a big blow for him
all right well we'll let you go Favi
enjoy uh the rest of your day and we'll
see what you have tomorrow thank you
sorry sorry Fabby inquiring minds want
to know uh now that you played tennis on
the rest day uh who did you beat who did
you lose to
okay so I I played Peter first and I
lost
ooh commentators do it again that I
played Maxime and I won
did I beat you Alejandro yes
[Laughter]
and I lost two
um a player I hadn't met before uziah
Josiah I'm telling you that you will
never see this person again you were not
allowed in the tennis court it's not
allowed any anywhere near me
it was way too good all of us no he he
was by far the yeah he was a bit strong
as tennis player Among Us yeah
all right papi thank you so much uh for
joining us and sharing your thoughts and
uh wow it was uh it was a nice interview
it was very very very very very nice
peter we are having one of the most
decisive games of the singfield cup
2022. it seems like there will be
extremely likely that we will only see
one draw today and that will be the game
between the one we just spoke about yeah
she will uh has drawn his game against
Fabiano white one two games and uh
uh I I I don't what they should be
winning yeah I don't want to uh you know
exaggerate that's not my intent
hyperbole but is it I mean Wesley has
played a Flawless game I mean he played
a very very nice game I mean he just
somehow he got a solid position maybe uh
Hans overreacted got his Bishop into
trouble and then once Wesley got in the
upper hand he's been nursing it to this
position and this is fantastic yeah very
very nice place
yeah and you have to go back to that
moment where
honestly everything Hans was doing in
the opening was entirely okay right but
you had to see before
and it's just it's just such a difficult
move to find and and Hans didn't manage
to find it and once you don't see those
ideas of before Queen B3 and you just
don't see them right because the you
know the square is unavailable and your
Bishop is about to get picked up and you
have to make a quiet move on the other
side of the board those you miss like
every day of the week absolutely
absolutely normal that you don't see it
uh and yeah once once 92 was played one
sort of control was relinquished
Blick is just better and Wesley seems to
have not you know let go of that
Advantage ever since yeah if you look at
this position uh black has put his
Knight on H5 put the pawn pardon me put
the pawn back on B2 for just a moment
you could win B3 instantly he comes to
your mind because the Knight is offside
somehow while the pawn is on B3 you stop
looking at B4 and squared the square
just doesn't exist in your in your field
of vision and then with very good well
precise play uh excellent yeah and you
have to wonder I would assume that
extremely precise defense from here
maybe defends this position for white I
get the feeling that it might not be
enough against absolute best play
exactly but from the very beginning I
was saying that you know getting
specifically these types of positions
against Wesley is like very very
difficult because he will just he will
never hurry he will exploit every single
opportunity to you know make his
position ever so slightly better and he
he will calculate
cleanly for for the rest of the game and
this is what we're watching yeah we're
we're seeing it in
real time and uh
I think it's three I think a three is
maybe the best choice I think that
position after D6 has to be lost simply
because black just switches to winning
the entire Queen side how did it go
quick King takes Knight F4 does force us
to play G5 now very importantly after G5
H5 is unplayable because we can actually
take we get Bishop D4 and then F5 just
in time otherwise I was about to say yes
otherwise it would have been maybe an
interesting try for white to it that's
right it's not uh you protect the h8
yeah so you have to play hgfg and then
the Knight doesn't really have
particularly good squares you can play
Knight H3 force me to play G4 but you
lack an opportunity to attack that pawn
straight away like you probably maybe
actually go Knight G5 here right
but I will play King D5 and once you
play something like Knight F7
I'm just not even going to address the
idea of Knight H6 I think I'm just kind
of going forward I mean Knight D6 kind
of bothers me though 96 doesn't bother
me at all but 96 does bother me a little
bit so let's play Bishop C5 maybe okay
wait for you to play Knight H6 which
I'll block but you will have to and then
I go King D4 and this is how you take
over the the queen side pawns and I I
think this pretty much always ends up
being lost even though yeah the one
we're currently discussing yeah it
definitely gets played out because right
yeah
like Bishop f8 I guess yeah I suspect
it's still winning honestly because uh
you you will not be able to trade the A4
Pawn for any of mine no and then they
start running and yes the pawn can get
to F7 but it shouldn't be quick enough
but this is clearly you know something
that needs to be uh you know debated
yeah
feels like it should be a win and this
is a draw apparently only two moves but
this is a draw
four draws on Kingsley okay my intention
when I put the pawn on a if I was trying
to get my king to B3 something like this
yeah
it's in the it's in the table place now
and it says draw yeah wow I wouldn't
have guessed that actually neither would
I would just I would expect this to not
be quick enough but apparently this is
just just quick enough yeah okay
um which means that I've already
misplayed it somewhere along the way and
we can't really feel it you were closely
aware yeah no no no you again from the
current position we're very close to the
current position I tried to move D6 and
uh the other one you wanted to try was
actually F3 F3 is also sort of an
attempt yeah but uh as long as we don't
take on F3 which I think would be a
large mistake allowing the Knight to get
there four I like this is I continue
liking Bishop the thing Bishop B8 is a
clever move and this is where you're
kind of debating with
same ideas uh just your shouldering and
White's pieces Kevin looks at this
bishop C5 is just stronger because white
has just no reply it appears to be at
Swang yeah because like right we've
denied even the E3 Square to tonight
yes we have we've denied absolutely
everything here yeah 5B Fabi just knows
this stuff yeah and we I'll defer to
Fabi I'm very very happily here so yeah
just not here to defend himself we can
well I'm promoting him okay so he
appears to be he appears to be unwilling
to promote himself there for a second
there I was a bit surprised because he
was given a very you know a gilded
opportunity to do some self-promotion
and uh I don't know said no to it you
know once he got defeated in tennis I
mean it's really it was kind of a
depressed I mean it depends who you lose
to but yeah losing losing to me clearly
he clearly has put a very very serious
dampener on his on his mode yeah
grandfather to work day I mean but like
yesterday absolutely rookie mistake by
5A yesterday rookie yeah he played Peter
first yeah oh yeah you got to get let
the old guy wear himself I don't know I
agree with that it's well known yeah
yeah that's that's Elementary you've got
to go yeah come on
that is one point
uh is this as bad as Peter and I are
making it out to be minus five mine is
five there's no hope wow I was thinking
is like maybe minus two minus five I'm
gonna give it a rest this is terrible
and I think these 36 has been played yet
as quickly King takes the Knight F4
everything that you guys were expecting
of course G5 is going to be played
because I think I figured it out
actually after G5 takes takes like if we
continue the line I was discussing
Knight H3 G4 Knight G5 I think we
actually give like we cleaned the Jeep
on surprisingly we go King E5 and if you
go Knight F7 Knight D6 E3 actually wins
the Jeep Yeah by fourth right yeah yeah
yeah there's no way yeah like we don't
actually have to win the way I assume we
have to win because FB Bishop E3 and
then G3 king of three and it's just a
fool we might be going towards something
very similar because we have the move
Knight G5 and I don't see the difference
right you can still go no that was
exactly the line we were discussing
King F4 is lost
yeah I don't see any good moves I just
don't see anything yeah and if you start
pushing on the queen side I will maybe
first improve the position of my bishop
and then I will choose whether I want to
start picking up something on the queen
side it also makes your older plan so
much stronger yeah if we go C4 as the
engine is trying to play I mean all
right thank you for all those variations
we just looked at except I'm up like
three Tempe because instead of going
this way I just go directly and take
care of Pawns exactly Wesley in
excellent position pole position in the
tournament winning a great game with
black that is he's just going to be in a
massive uh Advantage going into the last
few rounds of the tournament to win this
event and remember that the only hope
for the other players is to try to catch
up with him tomorrow because tomorrow's
Wesley's rest day absolutely yeah and
interestingly uh Wesley is can we see
the grand yes maybe we can see the
graphics I think alireza is three points
above him uh it was 26 and a half 25 and
a half 22 and a half
is here exactly exactly three points
above him so he firstly wins by the way
if but the one is back to 50 but mvl is
sort of out of the running a little bit
because he's on minus two my point is
yes if Wesley wind wins this tournament
yeah he gets to uh 35 and a half
that's a lot yeah but if alireza takes
clear second we do get a tie break on
Tuesday on Monday but yes yeah that's
why you've been talking about playoffs
uh whenever we go through our schedule
it's very clever view uh that that you
perceived there was a potential type a
potential tie there yeah so it's it's
very much it's very much possible I mean
there's still three rounds to go and
plenty of permutations available there
but uh with precisely three a
three-point different difference between
them and 13 for First and Ten for second
exactly this does look like it's not
even that far-fetched and for Lavon by
the way again he just he pulled himself
back to the 50 Mark but he has the same
point number of points as Wesley he's
just gonna have to win a lot of the
remaining games if you will yeah he is
giving Wesley a full point Head Start
and in this particular tournament they
are tied for third in the grandchester
but Wesley is on plus two and the one
has just gotten back to 50 exactly 95
played in the meantime yes we're
assuming King E5 King D5 probably also
wins but I think King E5 is cleaner King
E5 and again I like this this uh
suggestion that you've made here with
this king of one here I think yeah that
was something I was trying to calculate
If instead of 96 you go king of one king
F1 yeah
my question is should I pause yeah we
can go Bishop C5 but then there's 98 we
can even go king of three right and then
which takes it so
so we can go Bishop C5 here or perhaps
we can maybe even allow ourselves to
play E3
I was trying to figure that out we play
three white obviously has to take it
cannot be ignored I take with the bishop
okay you cannot attack my B7 Pawn
because then king of three will come and
then G3 will come and this is once again
really horrible and now I go Bishop C5 I
know 98 I'm not actually restricting
that Knight well enough well I mean even
here yeah maybe even this is player A5
though white gets to trade some stuff
I'm not sure how happy I am with this
with black I we might still be winning
but I think I'm cutting I'm cutting the
margins a little bit too close
that's that's okay so maybe Knight F7
King F1 is a way to at least
uh to at least inquire politely
we'll see and King D5 people should
should still be okay I don't see
anything wrong with Kingdom but then
after Knight F7 I have to calculate
right Knight of seven Knight H6 that
kind of stuff that we were discussing a
bit right
and I didn't quite follow one thing I
thought you could just trade the g-pawn
for the F2 Pawn oh just Bishop B8 here
yeah yes sure yeah maybe maybe this is
actually the cleanest just Bishop B8 go
G3 right I mean you're still cool yeah
and then like neither five which before
everything is still entirely under
control they're not very very dominated
by that Bishop exactly yeah we're still
cooking C5 King before next couple the
expression beating a dead horse yeah
it's that it's it's that bad we're just
vlogging just just choose a choose a way
to win right even in the one that you
almost made into a draw yeah it's
winning if you for example go uh instead
of Bishop B8 in this position you were
trying to go directly right King D4
Knight H6 here here you just have to be
a little bit careful not to allow oh
yeah Bishop Bishop Bishop D4 dominate
The Knight it's not a difficult move to
see from afar and then you just collect
everybody else without losing the E4
Pawn or at least losing it much much
slower yes yeah yeah I mean I like that
it does feel it does feel like it's it's
going to be difficult to misplay this
position badly absolutely
but where there's a will absolutely
there is a way absolutely
trust me on that one oh boy uh wow as
the the joke goes here difficult does
not mean impossible
for Wesley so I mean again as we've been
saying this will bring up to plus two
put them in Pole Position
hit the trampoline if he can get that
extra bonus point of the grand Chester
and he's no stranger to winning this
Grand chest story yeah very very well in
his event sorry no I I suddenly remember
that I think uh it was Anastasia
specifically I think when we started
covering the uh of
was it before I think it was before this
tournament I think Anastasia
specifically said that she wants Wesley
to win because everybody else who won it
won it twice and he's only won the the
the the singfield cup specifically once
I think so there's some symmetry
geometry sorry Alejandra yeah of course
the only other person that's only one
who wants is not here yeah he's not here
yeah but Wesley would be tying things up
right sometimes you see a dominant
performance by one player it's like
their tournament they win it over and
over again not the zingfield cup it gets
bounced around by some of the top
players a lot the fact that a lot of
these players have won it twice of
course with the caveat that three of
them tied for first place in 2000 I want
to say 18. uh it of course adds to that
number but it's still funny nobody has a
dominance over this event despite the
fact that the world champion has been
playing here pretty consistently not
every single year but pretty
consistently through that dominance
fabianos uh plus seven this streak uh
will go down for a long long time uh do
we have a move
King 507 on the board and and Wesley is
thinking King F4 is stronger than
everything else but even kind of really
strange decisions such as planking D4 uh
actually it's not that strange like I I
would be kind of loath to play that
because my d8 exists and 96 exists but
the engine doesn't really mind it's
collecting yeah I assume we just go you
go in you collect yeah King c397 Bishop
B6 or Bishop B6 as well yeah
uh
is a very logical way and now you have
to spend Tempe just making sure you
don't allow a queen uh and then Wesley
will switch to winning the entire Queen
side exactly safely removing all the
counter play on the other side of the
board so what's cleanest after King F1
here Alejandra just E3
you can pre-move E3 pretty much E3 in
this position you can play A5 it doesn't
matter about E3 I like it takes takes
before and yes it's true that I don't
have King F3 because of these checks but
I can just hide here and the Knight is
too far away oh yeah the third of King
H3 and G3 is just winning what if we
play King G2 instead of B4 yeah then I
just as first it wants to paralyze this
position yeah the pawns on dark squares
so the bishop can defend them and then
the king just moves over yeah and then
you just run and you think yeah that
makes a lot of sense yeah just play A5
B6 put the bishop on C5 and then we just
Waltz over that's it that's very good
technique yeah I must say that's very
nice this one this one I think is safely
resignable I think there's no at this
point it looks like yeah it's uh it's
not gonna be and once again let me just
remind our viewers that uh Hans Neiman
will be joining our show uh after this
game and uh we are soliciting any of
your questions that you might have
Anastasia will be very probably she's
got a collection
she will be feeding uh Alejandro and you
can also so
ask the commentators whatever they might
want to share with you we don't we know
all we tell little and uh there that's
the way to do it I don't think that
we've ever either of us have ever been
accused of of telling or saying little
that's true
but uh there's a the way tell our
viewers a way to contact us yeah we can
you can tweet at St Louis chess club on
on Twitter obviously or use any of the
the live chats excellent that's the wish
of which there are many that's the way
to do it that's the way to do it King f4
on the board okay
thinking and probably coming to a
depressing realization that this is not
a particularly difficult conversion from
here on out no E3 and uh King F1 played
King yeah there's there's a number of
things you can do you can even uh you
know spend a full Tempo on a6a5 here if
you if you were so inclined but I don't
think it's necessary and being told that
we are in fact getting questions all day
uh the the reality is they weren't
directed to that
I mean nobody cares about our opinions
and that's that's how it should be right
right they get our opinions whether they
solution them or not but precisely well
you will like them
it will listen to them and you will like
them you will like them and you'll be
happy
um King F1
um yeah no I really liked what Alejandro
was saying play E3 yeah play three take
a threat of making a new Queen on the G
file uh Force this pretty much and
really just freeze the queen side with
A5 B6 that means that those pawns are
never traded and the King just goes
after them the other way yeah very very
very very straightforward and uh as a
kind of a final final insult here A1 is
the correct color as well so there's
really nothing for you to look forward
to yeah even if we can envisage you and
visit some kind of a situation where you
can sacrifice give up everything for for
everything else but the a pawn you're
still losing I had that you're still
losing that's harsh
that is Harsh
and as you say uh what's the time
situation they both have plenty uh
Wesley somewhat surprisingly unless it's
still his first time control time which
probably it isn't I think it is
but it might be I I get the feeling it
might be yeah we've played enough moves
I think that's his first time control
yeah so so Wesley actually has 44
minutes against 28 for Hans Hans I think
has finally run out of his first answer
yeah yeah exactly right no that's that's
not right right Bishop B6 there bye bye
very quiet move but still winning
um still winning doesn't really spoil
anything but Bishop B6 is that a way of
saying the Knight gets trapped if the
Knight goes to D6
if you move the knight from F7 you
actually Queen the pawn
yeah you split yeah and now we go king
of three and we take one of two simply
yeah and we've we've won an additional
pawn and then we have two Runners gotcha
yeah so so Knight D6 on the board after
this uh yeah three king or three I think
he won something like Knight c495 check
but then King F4 just wins very very
comfortably for Wesley like yeah it's
not a difficult calculation yeah you run
out of five king of 496 King King G5 and
you'll no longer really have anything
sensible and then the bishop will just
go back to D4 yeah control the entire
the entire board again yeah and and
Knight c29 94.92
maybe would be a slightly better try
um
but unfortunately with the light on D2
we don't even have to control the bishop
anymore just went on the sport right
because there's a there's an E3 check
there that is a nice uh
nice way of finishing things to be sure
so this one is not not really far away
from being concluded the after king of
three you don't really have very much
very much choice
as white
Hans Neiman looks uh to be in great
distress at the moment as he's
nothing to be done but tip your hat and
say Wesley so well played oh no what a
game right now what do you think about
it what a game by Wesley right I mean he
neutralized you they're even fully
neutralize the opening like Hans played
this interesting b3c4 setup got the
moment that Hans played this move H4 he
looked at the position and said ah
you're Bishop
it's kind of funny looking
G3 when I saw the move G3 I kind of
understood it but I you immediately as a
grand master I think started looking at
this bishop 25 and thinking okay I need
to actually be mindful that it doesn't
get caught right uh and after A6 he
played a bunch of moves and it was this
precise moment when Hans plays the move
H4 that Wesley didn't skip a beat he
played Knight H5 and since then it's
been it's been downhill for white
because he had to find this ridiculous
computer line he didn't find it and
after Knight H5 C takes D5 C takes D5
uh Knight G2 F6 Bishop B8 saving the
bishop this excellent move King F7 I
mean there are other options there was
Queen D7 you could have moved that night
you could have moved the bishop to B4
but king of seven is the most accurate
understanding that White's idea is to
play G4 take on H5 and the king is
actually very useful in defending that
square on G6 and I think that is the
resignation yes no we had the handshake
oh we had a handshake and the done deal
as they're talking about this ending uh
Wesley so our new well yeah
he came into the round was our
tournament leader mathematics
mathematically speaking Yeah but now he
actually is in the tournament on plus
two and nobody else is on plus two is on
plus one and alireza is on plus one
right so he is he is now sort of a not
not really a half a point but but the
one Victory ahead
of his uh two nearest pursuers yeah
there's our official
photographer Leonard
Otis with the with the pink buzz
buzz cut yeah I did not see it there
yesterday and that is a big change and
there's our International Arbiter Chris
bird with no color
well he's going for you know he's a
different look it's a different look
as we wait for the players and their
interviews no guys I'm just impressed I
mean Wesley sometimes plays these games
where right it feels like a Truck Yeah
it feels like you you make one and
accuracy somewhere and and then you just
get very very carefully you know kind of
with great care and attention paid to
you yeah right but you just get uh well
one alive one one of the things about
this Victory and about what we're saying
about Wesley in particular is it's so
hard to keep control of these guys you
know like you somehow you slip here you
slip there you allow them to climb back
into it Fabi MBL nepo they all they you
know you you've given them an
opportunity and they'll find a way to
escape but Wesley keeps the control as
he did in this game
very well and the moment he was given an
opportunity to kind of really bounce
like that that perhaps slight inaccuracy
maybe not even slight in accuracy by
Hans which allowed this very nice
maneuver of Bishop H2 revoking Knight F3
back in English before from them onwards
you kind of knew how that movie ended
right uh and uh Wesley did indeed
convert very convincingly three of
Victories as we get ready for our
interviews once again uh round six
incredible round of results uh rest they
rest they definitely doing people know
well I mean some people know harm and uh
a great deal of harm to others as we as
we watch a lot of people lose you know
as it happens when a lot of people win
exactly uh but uh wow um I must say that
I didn't expect such a decisive number
of games but also one of the other
things Peter I just wanted to say about
this tournament
wonderful variety of openings
we get to talk about a lot of different
positions exploring especially
[Laughter]
see that's why he's off my CR my
Christmas wishlist how many petrols I
think it's the most popular very uh
defensive tournament right there's been
a I think a reasonable number of nidor
so I think in my mind it's split between
Petrov and neither and I don't pay I
mean and there's probably like cotton
has to yeah has to be in the mix I don't
care if it's Play Between the Petrov and
the night of us how long it's not split
between the Petrified and the Berlin oh
yeah I'm all good okay you're good
you're good and we have some englishes I
mean again the English today was the
roller coaster oh yeah very shocking
that Shaq by the way again it took what
was a clearly advantages and just turned
it into a mess just literally just this
this whole sequence starting from Knight
f8 I mean just felt wrong and it's you
have to wonder he was playing so well
until that moment for for Shaq who is
definitely one of the best players in
this tournament in terms of in terms of
how he treats unclear Dynamic positions
he is he's throughout his career has
been the absolute master of you know the
mess the Mayhem and today he clearly won
the first phase and then just well it
really is like what seven moves well
here we are Bishops maybe as as Ali Reza
he came in and he freely confessed
Bishop F2 blunder oh you must feeling
terrible like now I'm in a terrible so
this is move 22 and the game ended on
move 28 from White so uh Shaq actually
managed to make six moves out of here
to go from a position which I think
calling it a winning position for black
is a bit strong considering how messy it
is but definitely a much better position
for black so he made six moves in
resigned wow uh this is extremely
unusual for him yeah he will be I think
bitterly disappointed with that because
he played very very well out of the open
and here we were just thinking that a
very normal
you know protecting this Pawn on e4 with
Bishop to B7 you know you've got Queen
A2 if you've got Queen D6 Queen D6 Queen
E6 F7 F6 very importantly I want to
include F7 F6 as early as possible just
to no longer have to really worry about
the bishop very much and that would have
put the position definitely in uh Shaq's
favor didn't happen as none of this
happened yeah but we don't have an
interview so let's uh not remember about
this uh over to you Alejandro the clear
leader of the tournament Wesley saw is
joining us Wesley you've switched a
little bit not a Berlin but a Petrov
where your knowledge on here
uh yeah before we talk about the game
just let's say first of all uh very
pleased to win and all glory to God of
course for giving me the win
um
yeah the Petrov is twofold basically
Fabiano played it against me the other
day
and so I thought I'd try it with the
other side secondly we had the rest day
yesterday and Hans prepares extremely
extremely well the openings like
sometimes we can even predict so I
thought why not the pet off also if you
check on the database it doesn't have
like he has hundreds of games with
Knight C6 for both colors even one of
the petrophy only has a few
and he generally plays very tedious
lines like he plays Knight d3rd mode
before
and so I thought I tried today but um
um yeah it worked out well I mean
obviously I just want to play solid
today and with all the drama just try to
survive
but Hans was obviously playing for a win
as he said he would but I think I was
I equalized well in the opening like he
didn't play the most uh critical lines
I'm not sure where his preparation ended
maybe it ended on move 15 when he played
Bishop E5
and here I had a similar position where
white plays Bishop E5 then you play 94
Knight F6 to because the D5 Pawn is the
only problem right I mean black as other
moves but I thought this equalizes uh
well maybe he can try like I don't know
Queen F5 or something
like Queen F5 G6 Queen H3
and try to start up something of course
it should be nothing I'm sure the engine
gives all zeros
but um in the game after I played G6 A6
I see no problems for black because he
doesn't have any
any place to create uh anything and I
mean if he plays like Knight F5 in two
minutes then
then whatever but I'm talking about no I
meant like when I played G6 ah 95 here
whoa yeah I thought 95 gf5 and then
Knight H4
um oh no no not text not H4 that makes
more sense actually and then you have an
87 oh wait a minute wait so the point is
after 97 you're playing Knight F5
yeah this is not that clear actually
yeah maybe not Knight G7 yeah maybe not
93 I think Knight E4 94 95 and then some
F6 F6 maybe bishop F6 or maybe bishop F6
yeah huh oh Bishop F6 though yeah right
but and then yeah so I saw something
like this because you know how G3 even
if it did something yeah but yeah and
the game was very tedious and I thought
H4 by the way were you surprised about
this move G3 not because he wants to
take take ncd5 without having to worry
about Knight F4 like if white ones if
White Once the door he can take on F6
and then cd5 I guess Knight F4 Queen E4
and then just play this the structure
yeah I mean it's completely equal so I
mean yeah he didn't choose the most
critical lines I thought H4 was a
blunder because after Knight H5 if
Bishop's getting trapped right and I
didn't see a way for him to equalize
here like he could sacrifice a piece
with Knight G4 then I play F6
then he can he thought he could give a
check or he can play Rook B one battle
rugby one I can play like bishop f8 or
something or queen D7 and I think
black's better in online but
yeah we also felt like that I will tell
you that there was a way to equalize the
position yeah I didn't I didn't see a
way to equal life after Knight H5 yeah
after CD CD you might not believe it but
it's B4 ah
yeah I wonder what the reaction I wanted
to get
um before yeah that's that's exactly the
reaction before yeah yeah an epic one
bit there you have yes no it's still
messy after that the computer says zeros
but of course and the point is that you
don't want to play Queen D7 because
after Queen E7 Knight G4 F6 he always
gains a Tempo attacking the queen no I
think I think we were playing Queen B3
kg8 and uh Rook G1 right F6 Bishop
Bishop B8 Bishop like I didn't even see
this bishop B8 it just it's so hard to
find moves like that but I guess yes
that was impossible yeah okay I have an
engine yeah and not not a strong engine
I'm a strong engine but it still sees
very good moves yeah before I assume
I don't know maybe Magnus would find
before I don't know but he's a pretty
strong player tell us a little bit about
this end game you got all the way here
it felt like your opponent was under a
lot of pressure you exchanged the Rooks
there was not a lot of choices at one
point the line also moved 26th like
instead of Knight takes F4 I thought he
could play hghg 95 fe5 Knight F4 ef4 and
then
um so look
if H5 I have broke G8 I guess huh and
then Bishop F6 yeah it's nice that it's
a Chuck and so if the H5 you can play
Rook D E1 Rook d e one uh-huh pinning
but I think Queen fate is winning for
black Aquin C8 and you have this
important move Queen G4 coming in to
defend everything yeah Rook E6 Queen
takes through yeah this is too much
material but I think if I have Queen V8
I'm not winning oh really yeah I think
26 h54 yeah Queen do you think for H5
well let me put this quick Queen D6 H5
in this position and now I assume rookie
six is the idea no hd6 IHG under your
Bishop is hanging I mean I can make a
draw with Rook 88 or something right any
passing move is actually a draw yeah
okay see it yeah but I mean but why
would of course when he played H4 I
wanted to try to yeah but I mean I
thought he would go for something like
this but I think it doesn't work so did
you think the engine was that bad for
him
um I I thought it's unpleasant
but I of course it's uh not clear if
you're gonna win like I think maybe in
the game I was regretting when I played
Bishop F4 I thought the winning plan
here well the winning plan is too much
but I thought the best plan is to play
Bishop before Yes actually the angels
are very adamant about this move as well
yeah the thing is like I got played
Bishop B4 earlier but if I put Bishop on
D6 but I think Bishop B4 and then
basically the Knight cannot move because
beginning the game he got Queen fitter
and some counter fluency but I think
Bishop B4 with very good chances the
point if you play Queen E4 and then King
E6 King F5 when you're 14 King 16.5
right and the Knight is controlled yeah
I didn't play this because I thought I
didn't see a win after King E2 Queen E4
Queen takes D takes Knight G1
or is it Knight G1 and then F but it's
gonna be winning yeah so yeah it's all
pretty bad King e16 E3
Ian I didn't find a win here but it
looks bad for black but I mean it's like
similar to half the game all right and
in the game when did you feel that you
finally had it all under control no
actually I messed it up like around so
around move 34 to 38 I was just
shuffling my pieces yes like I wasn't
sure where to put my king whether to
bring in H5 but it doesn't do anything
or all the way to H5 right yeah yeah it
looks pretty bad it doesn't do anything
but also like I wasn't sure where to put
my thing so around move 39 I was
actually figuring that it's probably
gonna be very very difficult to win this
and you know if it's a dirt it's a draw
that's fine because I would have been
happy with the draw anyway before the
game but I thought um
King Ito on move 42 was a serious
blunder right and you capitalized on it
yeah you probably missed Bishop H2 after
which I didn't see a draw anymore yeah
and you were absolutely correct the
Dallas has for 93 Bishop F4 it seems the
end game is just lost yeah I'm very
sharply placing it too because he's got
50 minutes on the clock
and uh animal beef is very solid for
white like I have to defend a little bit
but uh I mean I'm not sure what the
white and blue like I think the edges
were thinking Knight E2
uh
and then yeah can you fix nice
15 E6 it still looks very very dangerous
to my eyes it's definitely yeah
it definitely is dangerous but hope for
survival King E2 seems like Bishop H2
finished half the game
yeah he probably missed it like he was
calculating Bishop F4 Queen winning 4D
for F3 no this is very clever because
the Knight is actually worst place on F3
than it is on G1 yeah and if he plays
Knight H3 I have in this position
when they have a king this example yeah
I thinking E6 was the ending yeah yeah
yeah
was just a shocker okay H4 was also a
shocker so hands made two blunders today
yeah Wesley a nice win with the black
pieces you are now in pole position do
you feel you're ready to win your second
sing feel Cup oh one one game at that
time but first of all I'd like to thank
the many people like the Saint Louis
chess club
also the anti-cheating team so like Tony
Rich uh Joy Bray also uh the Arbiters
Chris bird and of course to Rex
engineering field by the way belated
happy birthday to him and uh yeah to you
guys also to at the Alejandro and Peter
and Yasser for all the considerate
things that you do every day I mean
obviously this tournament is uh
a bit messed up with Magnus withdrawing
but hey he's the best player so I'm fine
with that but I'm really grateful for
the things that people did to secure
this tournament I mean of course I feel
sorry for Hans he's only 19 and there's
a tremendous amount of
pressure coming from everybody and we
still don't know 100 what really
happened or anything but my mother had a
talk with Tony Rich on the
with the day before and he said the
security here is is even better than the
White House so after he said that I was
very pleased with I'm really grateful to
the people who made this tournament
figure well there's a big claim we
certainly appreciate it you make our
lives easy because you play this
wonderful games like the one you did
today yeah I mean sometimes you
are happy to make a door and you win
sometimes you try to win and you can
make progress so that's just how chess
goes indeed well Wesley thank you for
this and good luck in the rest of your
tournament yeah I have a rest day
tomorrow that's also very good also not
bad yeah go watch the movies have a nice
meal try to get 12 hours of sleep and
that will be preparation of course yes
probably in the must win what is that
sorcerer yeah he said 12 hours of sleep
yeah possible I haven't done that yet if
you wanna sleep for 12 hours you have to
lie in bed for 14 hours
there's a secret to success guys 12
hours of sleep 14 hours of bed rest yeah
that's why it's called rest days
very good all right thank you Wesley for
joining us here thank you guys back to
you uh thank you Wesley uh for your
interview and your kind thoughts I just
want to say that unfortunately in the
world of Chess one of the terrible
terrible things that happened Peter is
sometimes you lose a game of chess and
when that happens
hopefully hopefully tomorrow we've saved
all of your very thoughtful I'm sure
very thoughtful questions that you want
to have that you wanted to uh to ask
hands we will not be doing this today
because uh I think uh very
understandably and I always felt that
absolutely requiring interviews after
after losses I understand why it's done
sometimes but if if you can actually
avoid doing that players really
appreciate it absolutely absolutely but
we will we will get an opportunity to
talk to Hans before the tournament is
over and this was not Our intention and
we will ask them eventually the
questions will get asked absolutely and
of course we have in studio with
Alejandro and Anastasia who has our
latest updates on our social media
Alejandro
hello everyone once again after it's
been a long day actually
um it's actually I wanted to mention
such a big contrast you go to the
playing area it's so quiet everything is
calm players are thinking Arbiters are
working everything seemed to be under
full control and then you open social
media and you see you know all this mess
a lot of drama and people are still
discussing everything uh Hikaru Nakamura
just one hour ago came out with a new
video like an answer for Hans interview
and of course everybody and I was
checking what his thoughts and basically
I would just point out one thing what he
said mentioning that he never accused
Hans directly in cheating over the board
so this is what he wanted to mention and
of course everybody will check now this
interview I'm sure all players went to
check their social media and I would
like to show some numbers our team
prepared really interesting numbers and
statistics so you can see the first days
when hashtag grunge's tour I mean
started and it was like 10 28k views and
when the news came out it was two and a
half million views I think the numbers
are really great and the kids are
falling but still we're pretty high so I
mean the tournament is really really
popular because of the whole drama and
also because it's the tournament is
stronger itself and I would like also to
show a few more tweets which came out
during the round first of all I mean I
published this is a photo of Alejandro
ready to start the show and we got the
answer of anishogiri who said that he is
looking a little bit suspicious I guess
this is what Anish meant yes
that was the first one I also wanted to
mention one a tweet from katakowski who
remembered his match against Gary
Kasparov back in 1992 when he was the
game when he won the game at age of 18s
and he was happy that nobody accused me
in cheating after the game at that times
I did order the nickname of biological
Computer Club
and uh one more tweet of Hikaru just
mentioned it so those who would like to
see the answer because I think we have a
like discussion already our hands comes
with some comments than the other
players also show up and um the last one
what I wanted to show you I was looking
for Magnus in those social media and I
found him I found him and the story is
Safari and tari I I hope it's a fresh
one I asked Ariana but he haven't
admitted yet but so that's where we
found Magnus at the moment I haven't
found him anymore might make a kind of a
slightly unsafe assumption that this is
water this is the coldest water
absolutely yes
yes it looks like it looks like actually
so again once again I would recommend to
all our followers in YouTube also to go
and follow us in Saint Louis chess club
and grantchester accounts and Twitter
Instagram and everywhere you can find us
in Facebook as well so um and I think it
was a really interesting day the the
story continues we will follow it
closely of course for the next days and
back to you Yasser and Peter Anastasia
thank you once again for uh keeping us
up to date Peter as we were coming on
show you were telling me about Peter
Heine on his trip home just share that
yeah well uh on the topic of twitch
today at Peter Heine magnus's coach
tweeted that a person sitting next to
him on an InterContinental flight flying
back home randomly asked him what he was
doing in the states and uh Peter heineb
who is an honest person replied chess
coaching and his his neighbor said so
what do you think on the recent chess
drama I'm pretty sure we can safely
assume the person asking did not know
who Peter Heine was so it must be it
must be quite funny in a slightly sad
sad kind of way for for the age there
true uh let's just take a look at our
current standings with the round six in
the history books Peter do the honors
please uh there we have it and the field
will sort of solidify the same same
number of games eventually but for now
we still have this situation with with a
different number of games but Wesley is
clearly in first this this much this
much we know and then we have a lot of
people on uh well not a lot of people we
have uh three people in three uh points
but two of them are actually tied for
second and five b is on 50 he is not
actually in effect tied with that there
is any publisher who only played five
games uh 11 hunts are now 150 as is
linear Dominguez uh maximum is on minus
two and as is uh so we only have two
people in the minus but both of them are
both of them lost today so they're very
much underwater
all right well I think that that really
sums up once again another amazing
addition of the sinkfield cup round six
uh tomorrow of course round seven uh we
hope you enjoyed our coverage we kept
all of your questions for Hans and we
will be asking them and in the meanwhile
I'm gonna wish you all a very good night
thank you for staying us yes
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited